figaro live bonjour il est 18 heures et
on va vous faire vivre le tirage au sort
de la champion's league la ligue des
champions auquel va participer deux
clubs français le paris saint germain et
le losc lille puisque monaco a été
éliminé hier il n'y aura que deux clubs
et non 3g avec sébastien ferra salut
sébastien salut vincent comment ça va
bien ça va bien on ira jouer en ligue
des champions voilà on est là on est
ensemble pour 45 minutes une heure ça va
dépendre combien de temps durant la
cérémonie bien évidemment on ne peut pas
vous montrer les images puisque nous
n'avons pas les droits on n'a pas acheté
encore les droits pour vous diffusez le
tirage au sort mais gelé sur mon petit
écran qui est devant moi donc si l'on
regarde mon écran c'est normal ne vous
inquiétez pas mais on va décrypter un
peu tout ça vous faire le tirage au sort
en direct on vous fera vivre ça avec
ryad qui à la réalisation de ce live là
en ce moment il y a le générique sur le
site de l'uefa vous n'hésitez pas en
tout cas à nous poser toutes vos
questions déjà on va commencer par une
petite mise au point
comment ça marche le tirage au sort de
la ligue des champions ouais alors
comment ça marche c'est assez simple
donc on a des chapeaux 1 2 3 4 pour
avoir des groupes relativement équilibré
pour pas avoir toutes les tous les
prétendants au titre par exemple dans le
même groupe où tout plusieurs équipes
faibles dans le même donc on va voir
tirage au sort tout du long on va voir
d'abord toutes les équipes du chapeau 1
qui vont chacune se voir attribuer un
groupe ensuite les équipes du chapeau 2
du chapeau 3 du chapeau 4 et ainsi de
suite les groupes vont se remplir petit
à petit c'est pour ça que ça va être
assez lent au début puisque en plus on
va mettre d'abord les gros clubs dans
les chapeaux et on sera pas en compte
qu'ils ont contre qui on va jouer et ça
mettra sûrement un peu de temps pour
savoir exactement qui va jouer contre
qui alors que la cérémonie effectivement
vient de débuter il ya pas mal de
commentaires des supporters parisiens et
des parcs et des supporters du barça on
voit sur le live de l'uefa nasser ali
fille qui est sur place tous les
dirigeants des clubs européens sont sur
place pour être là pour commenter ils
réagiront juste après le tirage au sort
la première question que j'avais c est
ce qu il ya un favori pour ce tirage au
sort
favori en tout cas pour la ligue des
champions pour la ligue des champions
aujourd'hui
avant le début du mois de septembre
c'est quand même très compliqué d'en
donner un méga quand même trois quatre
équipes qui se dégage bien évidemment de
chelsea tenant du titre manchester city
finaliste donc vice champion d'europe on
pourrait rajouter le bayern munich est
encore très très fort le psg est
évidemment incontournable
on pourrait peut-être ajouter quelques
autres équipes mais personnellement je
pense que vraiment ces quatre là sortent
du lot aujourd'hui sur le papier après
on verra selon la forme selon les matchs
qui vont se dérouler parce qu'on sait
que ces équipes on les attend pas en
août ni en septembre on les attend à
partir de février voire mars avril il
faut il va falloir avoir de la
profondeur de banc c'est ce qui a
parfois manqué à des grosses équipes qui
pour autant on ont des bonnes équipes
pour pour performer mais effectivement
c'est en avril ou en mars que ça se joue
et ce à paris on a déjà fait les frais
oui voilà ils en ont fait les frais sur
sur plusieurs saisons plusieurs saisons
où ils ont un peu buté en huitièmes en
quarts où parfois on avait des phases de
groupes assez satisfaisante maintenant
l'heure de vérité pour ces équipes là
c'est évidemment la phase finale c'est
là-dessus qu'elles seront jugés le
tirage au sort c'est pour ces
prétendants au titre plus un
échauffement et là une façon de de se
mettre en jambes de se tester et de
tester des choses en ligue des champions
pendant ce temps-là l'uefa donnera nous
montrer les meilleurs moments on a vu
par exemple lionel messi au barça ce qui
n'existe plus malheureusement torts
allemands pour leur argent pour la ligue
1 au mans pour le dis carrément pour
paris on va être supporters de benfica
du psg de porto de madrid de chelsea qui
l'ont écrit n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions dites-nous pour vos clubs
contre qui vous voulez tomber contre qui
fait que vous voulez éviter on peut
peut-être commencer par ça quel serait
pour paris et lille on va peut-être
commencer par par lille vu que lille et
japon - ou peut-être déjà expliquer ça
comment on répartit les équipes on voit
que dans le chapeau 1 il ya lille est
dans le chapeau 2 il ya paris comment se
font enfin comment on choisit les
chapeaux alors comment choisir et
chapeau c'est très simple dans le
chapeau 1 on a le vainqueur de la ligue
des champions à savoir en l'occurrence
chelsea on a aussi le vainqueur de la
ligue europa villarreal et ensuite on a
les champions nationaux des pays qui
sont les mieux classés à l'indicé uefa
donc en l'occurrence l'allemagne
l'espagne l'angleterre l'italie la
france et le portugal donc le fait les
deux champions ça ajoute pour être dans
le chapeau 1 et ensuite pour les
chapeaux 2 3 4 c'est très simple ça se
joue à l'indicé uefa donc les équipes
qui ont le meilleur indice uefa sont
classés ensuite les 24 équipes restantes
et plus vous êtes classé plus vous avez
de chance d'être dans le chapeau 2 ou 3
alors d une première question de mickaël
qui était déjà avec nous hier pour le
lay mercato qui demande à être que les
sélectionneurs je pense qu'il parle des
entraîneurs des dirigeants doivent
donner une liste des joueurs comme pour
l'euro ou la coupe du monde ont inscrit
des joueurs pour la ligue des champions
et d'ailleurs ça peut poser parfois de
quelques petits soucis bien sûr oui y'a
que limite de joueurs qui est inscrit je
crois qu'elle est de 25 habituellement
je me demande si elle n'a pas été
élargie avec la crise locaux vides pour
pour élargir un petit peu les effectifs
mais effectivement il ya une limite de
joueur qui peut être inscrits donc
certains joueurs en font parfois les
frais alors c'est plutôt des joueurs qui
sont appelés 1,10 est indésirable dans
leurs clubs qui sont un peu un peu
réserviste mais effectivement il ya qu
une certaine limite de joueur qui peut
être inscrits par un club alors qu'on
est en train de voir les images sur le
site de l'uefa compte toujours pas vous
montrer de chelsea qui est le tenant du
titre chelsea qui a battu manchester
city chelsea qui était un peu une équipe
on va peut-être pas surprise mais qui en
début de saison dernière avait un
entraîneur qui s'appelle frank lampard
d'une grande star et que ça n'a pas du
tout marché et au final il remporta
ligue des champions c'est assez
incroyable comme parcours ouais c'est
assez incroyable c était assez assez
assez marrant on va dire pour pour
chelsea qui avait déjà connu ça en 2012
il avait aussi limogé leur entraîneur en
cours de saison c'était andré vilas boas
si je me souviens bien et roberto di
matteo qui l'avait remplacé qui avait
remporté la ligue des champions là c'est
arrivé avec thomas strul qui s'est très
vite adapté à chelsea chelsea qui à ce
moment là et est donc qualifié pour les
huitièmes de finale ça c'est fait le
changement d'entraîneur je crois en
janvier et ça a été une petite surprise
parce que il avait tellement mal débuté
la saison avec frank lampard qu'on
parlait pas de chelsea comme d'un
prétendant au titre c'était une équipe
qui avait beaucoup dépensé sur le
mercato qui devait encore se construire
et finalement ça s'est fait très vite
pour eux ça c'est ça plutôt bien marché
il sortit city qui était le favori de la
finale alors que c'est ferrin le patron
de l'uefa vient de rentrer
je viens d'arriver sur l'estrade le
tirage au sort n'a pas commencé
normalement dans ce genre de situation
de cérémonie ça commence bout de 15
minutes donc restez avec nous n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions en attendant
on a une première question sur est ce
que la loi sur l'eau sur la différence
de buts est toujours en application
demandez aux monégasques lierre
malheureusement non non non ça n'existe
plus c'est pour ça que hier monaco ne
s'est pas eu des progressions alors
qu'il avait perdu 1 0 à l'aller puis ils
ont gagné 2 à 1 au retour mais
maintenant il n'y a plus de différence
de buts à l'aller et au retour et donc
c'est simple la règle de buts à
l'extérieur n'existent plus donc en
phase finale on n'aura pas cette règle
qui peut généralement changer beaucoup
de choses est-ce qu'on peut quand même
dire la raison sûrement principal de ce2
de cette règle est-ce que c'est pas pour
faire plus de spectacles à voir plus de
prolongation et plus de penalty oui
c'est une possibilité effectivement ça
favorise les chances d'avoir une
prolongation parce que auparavant il
fallait qu'il y a exactement le même
score à l'aller et au retour pour qu'ils
aient une prolongation maintenant on
peut y avoir tout à fait deux corps
différent et quand même avoir une
prolongation est donc une séance de tirs
au but ça va favoriser ça alors on à
aaron qui lui demande de faire le tirage
malheureusement ce n'est pas nous qui
nous occupons au nom n'est là que pour
mais nous on attend il ya la cérémonie
il faut leur dire à eux on n'y est pour
rien on a maxi qui lui demandait ce que
le psg peut tomber dans la poule du real
j'ai demandé à ryad de m en grand écran
les chapeaux pour qu'on puisse voir ça
en fait une équipe du chapeau un ton bac
ultime chapeau 2 quittons avec une
équipe du chapeau 3 avec thomas qu'une
équipe du chapeau 4 6 2 équipes se
retrouvent dans le même chapeau ils ne
peuvent pas affronter comme du coup le
psg et l'om reid il ya aussi d'autres
règles comme par exemple le fait que
deux clubs du même pays ne peuvent pas
tomber en groupe ensemble voilà
exactement donc on pourra pas avoir le
psg et lille dans le même groupe on
pourra pas avoir le real madrid et
l'atlético de madrid dans le même groupe
c'est assez important surtout pour pour
les grosses nations qui ont plusieurs
représentants ou pense à l'angleterre ou
à ou à l'allemagne ou à l'espagne donc
effectivement c'est une règle assez
importante parce que ça va limiter
parfois les choix très vite on pourra se
retrouver avec que deux ou trois
possibilités pour les clubs selon
l'équipe pour être tiré ensuite dans
leur groupe donc en l'occurrence paris
va quand même évité de très grosses
cylindrées avec le real madrid
liverpool man united le barça
ils peuvent avoir quand même un tirage
assez assez correcte en évitant toutes
ces équipes on en parlait tout à l'heure
en général le chapeau 1 est toujours
beaucoup plus fort au moins plus fort
que le chapeau 2 cette année le chapeau
1 on s'est posé la question c'est un peu
le chapeau 3 après ce qu'on se donne aux
fins et un peu on pourrait inverser les
deux on n'y verrait que du feu ouais
tout à fait c'est vrai qu'on a eu des
champions nationaux qui peuvent paraître
assez assez surprenant dans certains
championnats en tout cas lille c'était
une grosse surprise en france et
malheureusement c'est une équipe qui a
été un peu dépeuplé de ses joueurs et
surtout de son entraîneur le sporting
portugal qui est une surprise aussi au
portugal où j'ai avancé entre benfica
porto portugal étaient assez
impressionnants en plus en ligue des
champions la saison dernière qui avait
fait un quart de finale donc
effectivement on a des équipes assez
assez surprenante on peut le dire même
ligne ter qui c'est qui est un petit peu
explosé lors de l'intersaison quand il
perdu son entraîneur son attaquant
starbucks romelu lukaku donc
effectivement le chapeau 1 et peut-être
un peu moins fort kurun et saison
dernière alors on à angelo qui nous
demandent combien de temps va durer le
tirage au sort ça va dépendre de la
cérémonie en général non pour table sur
'une 45 minutes une heure oui c'est ça
en général vers 19 heures ce sera ce
sera terminé à peu près on en serait on
sera content qu'il va jouer le psg
compte qui va jouer lille on nous
demande si le psg est le nouveau grand
favori cette année le grand favori je
pense que c'est très difficile de nommer
un seul favori en tout cas aujourd'hui
en août ça me paraît ça me paraît
impossible même généralement avoir une
seule équipe qui sort vraiment du lot
c'est très compliqué on peut en avoir
deux trois comme on a dit tout à l'heure
le psg fait effectivement je pense
partie ces équipes on peut rajouter le
manchester city et chelsea qui sont
affrontées en finale l'an dernier le
bayern munich aussi je pense qu'il sera
un très sérieux candidat voilà je pense
que ces quatre équipes sortent vraiment
du lot alors que pendant ce temps là
alors je vous raconte ce qui se passe
pendant la cérémonie de l'uefa il ya nos
vaches qui rendu au docteur de l'équipe
du danemark parce que kristen ericsson
lors du dernier euro aille faire un
arrêt cardiaque et du coup ils passent
un sujet en ce moment dessus donc le
tirage au sort n'a toujours pas commencé
on vous l'a dit ça ne va pas démarrer
tout de suite tout de suite on a eu une
remarque assez marrante de quelqu'un qui
me disaient qu'ils et qu'il espérait que
mba paix aille au real perdre la finale
contre paris
c'est marrant en finale de la ligue des
champions mais est ce que le real peut
vraiment cette année arriver au final le
real aujourd'hui c'est quand même un
réal un petit peu amoindri sa réelle on
l'avait dit d'ailleurs hier dans le legs
marcato c'est un real qui a très peu
recruté cet été comme l'été dernier
c'est un real qui a perdu sergio ramos
est un homme clé en ligue des champions
lors des dernières saisons qui a perdu
raphaël varane aussi aujourd'hui le real
madrid ne fait pas vraiment partie des
favoris pour la ligue des champions même
en liga ça s'annonce un petit peu
compliqué c'est plutôt de l'atletico
qu'il repart favoris ce qui est assez
rare la clique au tenant du titre on
précise en espagne le real madrid fera
quand même partie des équipes qui seront
au rendez vous c'est une habitude
aujourd'hui ça assume et qu'il est quand
même très forte sur le papier il ya
toujours de grandes stars
c'est une équipe forte c'est pas une
équipe favorite aujourd'hui on nous
parle aussi de du fc barcelone le fc
barcelone de la même façon n'est pas le
grand barça déjà qui a perdu la durée
des si métiers en cause de ça et
maintenant on peut le dire en crise
depuis quelques années oui on a vu un
déclin assez assez lent et progressif
même s'il y avait une demi finale en
2020 qui c'est qui ce fait très très mal
terminée face au bayern munich 8 2
l'année dernière on les a vu sortir face
au psg en 8e de finale ça a été un peu
un choc pour pour le barça sorti en
huitièmes de finale je sais pas depuis
quand cela leur était pas arrivé mais ça
faisait ça faisait un moment je crois
face au psg ce nouveau prétendant au
titre donc c'était un gros coup dur le
départ de messi une grande crise
institutionnelle on sent que le barça a
été en souffrance ces dernières années
et aujourd'hui il le paye assez cher il
fait plus vraiment partie des favoris en
ligue des champions on nous demande du
coup
real madrid la bête blessée bayern psg
le barça est malade beaucoup de gens
confirme cette analyse mme heureusement
que varane est plus réelle il y en avait
marre des décomptes son camp et des
erreurs d'inattention je suis pas sûr
qu'ils vont y gagner avec milito et
lucio cordisco m non effectivement la
défense du real elle est peut-être un
peu moins sexy que les dernières années
en ligue des champions alors une
question d'affaires et je n'ai pas la
réponse où se tiendra la prochaine
finale de la ligue des champions
c'est la propre et voilà c'est sa
première cole devra vraiment une
question bravo c'est une très bonne
question
on vous laisse regarder on voulait
chercher sur internet s'est facilement
trouvable normalement on n'a pas la
réponse à cette question et bravo pour
vous avoir posé une colle
pendant ce temps là le la cérémonie se
poursuit toujours pas de tirage au sort
pour l'instant on peut être essayé de
parler du meilleur tirage et du pire
tirage
pour qui alors on va commencer par lille
parce qu'on nous a reproché dans le
cloud ailleurs d'être pro ps ge profile
peut-être un peu trop parlé du psg alors
qu'effectivement lille est champion de
france c'est censé être notre meilleure
chance
lille
c'est quoi leur meilleur tirage et c'est
quoi leur pire tirage selon toi alors si
on parle du meilleur tirage alors en
tout cas je sais pas si on peut revoir
les chapeaux pour se donner une idée
assez claire sur le meilleur tirage dans
le chapeau 2 en tout cas c'est très
difficile de désigner une équipe on
pourrait dire peut-être à l'essai vie
qui est peut-être un peu un cran en
dessous des autres même si ça peut
discuter avec le barça la juventus qui
ne sont absolument plus les prétendants
au titre qu'ils étaient les dernières
années dans le chapeau 3 un bon tirage
ça pourrait être à peut-être le zenit
saint pétersbourg ou salzburg aussi
qu'ils ne sont pas vraiment des habitués
de la phase finale qui sont parfois plus
souvent même en ligue europa dans le
chapeau 4 le meilleur tirage il est
assez clair c'est ces petits race paul
c'est le nouveau venu ce club moldave
c'est la première fois qu'on a un club
moldave ans en ligue des champions
maintenant sur le pire tirage dans le
chapeau 2 mois de chasseurs united
liverpool personnellement ça me paraît
quand même très très solide dans le
chapeau 3 on pourrait mentionner porto
quart de finaliste l'année dernière
l'atalanta aussi qui est qui commençait
à s'habituer à ces à ces rendez-vous est
dans le chapeau 4 la meilleure équipe sa
part assez clair la semino c'est
l'épouvantail effectivement de de
chapeau 4 on rappelle après il ya aussi
le besiktas jamais facile d'aller jouer
en turquie c'est ça peut être compliqué
le dynamo kiev qui oscille à wolsbourg
qui sort d'une bonne saison en allemagne
même si ce n'est pas le bayern ou le
borussia dortmund où la biche c'est
assez impressionnant yahoo mail qui me
demande quel club dans cette liste cela
pourrait être la surprise
danse et isla bon alors là on parle de
surprise on va on va partir du chapeau 3
du chapeau 4 ouais on veut c'est plus
les surprises voilà c'est ça juste des
sorties sauf l'île et du sporting ou
dans une moindre mesure d'être
villarreal effectivement alors si on
part vraiment du chapeau 3 du chapeau 4
le chapeau 4 ça serait quand même une
surprise pour pour lacer milan parce que
s'ils sont dans le chapeau 4 on le
rappelle ça se fait au coefficient uefa
c'est parce que ces dernières années on
ne voyait plus du tout en coupe d'europe
ou lorsqu on les voyait c'était en ligue
europa et ça faisait rarement de grands
parcours ça serait quand même une petite
surprise même par rapport à l'équipe
qu'ils ont sur le papier de les voir
aller jusqu'à en quarts ou en demies ça
serait une énorme surprise maintenant
dans les surprises possibles il faudra
peut-être se méfier de porto qui a déjà
fait un quart de finale qui peut encore
s'infiltrer là dedans on sait que l'ajax
et bien vous surprendre et aime bien
prendre un petit peu tout le monde à
contre-pied l'atalante a aussi qui est
passé un rien des demi finales en
dominant souvient contre le psg valoir
du tout pas loin du tout
ces équipes là peut-être un petit peu la
surprise on pourrait peut-être mentionné
l'ex ich
qui commence l'arrivée à malades à
maturité exactement je ne sais pas si on
peut autant parler de surprise parce
qu'il commence justement s'habitue à la
phase finale ou aux quarts de finale
voilà c'est plutôt là ces équipes là
qu'ils peuvent peut-être surprendre at
il dit nous on n'a pas parlé mais du
coup tout à l'heure tu as fait le
chapeau 2 3 4 meilleurs tirages pire
tirage le chapeau 1 quel est le meilleur
tirage pour paris et le pire le meilleur
tirage pour paris alors on rappelle que
le psg peut pas jouer avec lille le
meilleur tirage je pense qu'il est assez
clair c'est le sporting en tout cas sur
le papier ça a l'air d'être l'équipe la
moins forte et surtout la moins
expérimentée l'année dernière d'ailleurs
il ne joue même pas de coupe d'europe
puisqu'ils se font sortir en barrages de
ligue europa c'était une énorme énorme
désillusion pour pour ce club même si
claude n'est pas le plus habitué aux
coupes d'europe maintenant le pire
tirage basse ce sont les trois les trois
favoris avec le psg qui sont prétendants
au titre c'est à dire manchester city le
bayern et chelsea je pense que c'est là
que se trouve le le pire tirage après on
rappelle que c'est sur le papier et
quand on parle de meilleur et de pire
tirage c'est assez relatif parce que
qu'est-ce qu'un bon qu'est-ce qu'un
mauvais tirage est ce que c'est bien de
jouer une équipe d équipe assez faible
ou est-ce que c'est mieux de jouer déjà
des équipes assez fort pour vraiment se
tester et est davantage prêts aux
huitièmes de finale ça on peut se poser
la question
est ce qu'il ya vraiment un bon mauvais
tirage assez une question finalement
éternelle je passe sur qu'il ya tant de
bons ou de mauvais tirage en tout cas on
se rappelle aussi que le psg a rarement
eu énormément de chance dans ces tirages
sans que ces dernières années ça a l'air
un peu mieux mais au début de l'ère
qatarie ça devenait un peu une blague
c'était une répétition et à chaque fois
c'était quand même assez compliqué pour
eux wei marsa au rendez vous il ya le
bayern gagne le real madrid aussi
souvent souvent tu leur pour paris on
nous demande question assez intéressante
effectivement sur un peu plus globale
est-ce qu'on peut perdre la cinquième
place au classement et faire au
détriment du portugal qui a trois
représentants et quelles sont les
conséquences il me semble qu'on l'a déjà
qu'on va déjà la perdre alors on a on
l'a déjà perdue
maintenant selon ce qui peut se passer
cette saison ça peut ça peut encore
évoluer les conséquences on le rappelle
c'est le nombre c'est l'attribution des
places en coupe d'europe ou parfois pour
le troisième c'est de jouer un tour
préliminaire en plus donc ça peut pas
mal compliqué la tâche effectivement
cette saison la france clairement ligue
des champions je pense qu'elle va
compter uniquement sur le psg c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé lille aussi
parce que on peut le rappeler pour ceux
qui ne le savent pas c'est l'équipe sur
ses 32 équipes qui a le plus petit
coefficient uefa même derrière derrière
tiraspol le club moldave qui fait sa
première ligue des champions ça en dit
long sur les sur les ambitions que peut
avoir lille et sans même parler du
mercato qui sont connus qui a été assez
assez rude pour eux en ligue des
champions clairement on peut compter sur
le psg pour marquer des points en ligue
europa on n'en parlera pas on n'en
parlera pas aujourd'hui là aussi il ya
quelques clubs français qui peut jouer
leur chance mais c'est vrai que les
clubs portugais pour le coup qui sont à
la lutte donc avec la france au
classement gaza ils ont l'avantagé
d'avoir plusieurs équipes même s'ils
n'ont pas prétendant au titre comme le
psg on a une bonne question et je pense
que ça peut être la deuxième col alors
je sais que c'était le cas avant mais on
à françois gauthier qui nous demande vu
le contexte diplomatique il me semble
que les clubs russes et ukrainiens
doivent pas être dans le même groupe c
tandis que c'est toujours le cas c'est
toujours le cas c'est toujours le cas
donc on a certaines équipes le zénith
par exemple il pourra pas se retrouver
dans le groupe du dynamo kiev donc là
aussi ça réduit un petit peu les
possibilités selon qui peut-on des
arrêts qui servent là vous voyez donc on
a le zénith et le chakhtior et le dynamo
kiev en dessous effectivement le zénith
peut être une surprise aussi est-ce que
effectivement les amis de peut être une
surprise
je regardais facile de venir des clubs
russes jarret facile effectivement là
aussi un peu comme on disait pour les
captures sont de longs déplacements dans
les conditions parfois un peu un peu
difficile maintenant le zénith ces
dernières années c'est pas une équipe
qui a marqué beaucoup de points dans ces
phases de groupe en ligue des champions
c'est pas une équipe qui a fait trembler
beaucoup de monde c'est je ne sais pas
quand remonte le dernier huitième de
finale en tout cas c'était pas la saison
dernière je crois pas que c'était celle
d'avant non plus je ne sais pas ça peut
vraiment faire partie en tout cas c'est
vraiment à un petit outsider c'est un
outsider et c'est pas non plus un
outsider comme on l'a mentionné
peut-être les petits choux l'atalanta ou
l'ajax qui peut faire partie de ces gros
outsider qui peuvent vraiment surprendre
un petit peu tout le monde les unités
quand même un cran tous ces équipes là
je pense alors que l'équipe médicale
delà du danemark vient d'être félicités
on leur a remis à anne pas on leur a
remis un prix ils sont en train de
partir de la scène le tirage au sort
devrait commencer dans quelques temps on
la blanca et une autre personne et
mickaël qui nous parle de liverpool
blanca qui nous demandaient ce que
liverpool a une chance d'aller au bout
on se rappelle de l'an dernier la saison
de liverpool elle est quand même
dégommer par les blessures vandal qui se
blesse matip qui se blessent gomes qui
se blessent ils ont plus de défenseurs
centraux c'était c'était une saison
quand même assez galère est ce que cette
année ils peuvent revenir au top et
gagner avec des champions bien sûr
aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils font partie
un peu de ceux de ce deuxième lot on a
les quatre favoris donc city bayern
paris et celle ci en tout cas qu'il pour
moi sont les quatre qui se dégage
vraiment et en dessous oui dans les
équipes qui suivent et qui peuvent
espérer aller au bout il ya liverpool
effectivement le retour de blessure de
virgile van dyke c'est une énorme
nouvelle et on l'a vu sur le début de
saison en 1re ligue il est bien il est
en forme c'est c'est la meilleure recrue
en fait de liverpool cette année c'est
une équipe très forte qui se connaît
très bien avec un trio da taxe à la
manif herminio et du gotha qui s'est
très bien intégré c'est une équipe lui
qui peut tout à fait prétendre aller au
bout et ça fait partie aussi de ses
équipes je pense qu'on attend justement
en février sur la phase finale en tout
cas on les attend clairement au rendez
vous des huitièmes
alors on nous demande comment va se
dérouler la phase de poules comme mon
corps va débuter en tout cas la phase de
groupes de ligue des champions ça
commencera le 14 septembre le 14 et le
15 septembre mais ça va dépendre des
groupes effectivement des affiches c'est
assez long en rappel c'est un marathon
la finale en général ces femmes et j'en
oublie pas la date exacte pas si la date
exacte est déjà sorti mais c'est fin mai
début juin donc on est parti pour pas
mal de temps de football anc oui oui on
aura une belle saison de ligue des
champions la ligue des champions va nous
accompagner toute la saison ça c'est sûr
on aurait évidemment la petite trêve fin
décembre et puis le mois de janvier en
attendant les huitièmes de finale
jusqu'à ce moment où tout le monde va
attendre le retour de la ligue des
champions en huitièmes dé finale alors
on nous dit que tiraspol va surprendre
alors moi personnellement tiraspol je
vais pas vous mentir j'avais jamais vu
j'ai jamais vu un de leurs matches j'ai
juste vu quelques résumés ils nous ont
quand même sorti le dinamo zagreb ce
n'est pas n'importe quelle équipe bien
sûr qu'ils étaient qui était grande
favorite qui avait mis son prix comme
ils auront mis 3 0 à l'aller ils ont
tenu le 0-0 retour là bas
attention attention tiraspol bien sûr
ben on il faut toujours se méfier de
toute façon toutes les équipes sont deux
sont des équipes sérieuses abandonné on
n'est pas en ligue des champions par
hasard et évidemment sur le papier c'est
un peu moins impressionnant mais les
matches il faut les jouer alors c'est
sûr que pour manchester city chelsea ça
leur fait pas très très peur maintenant
il ya une place aussi de troisième dans
ce groupe à aller chercher pour aller
jouer ensuite la ligue europa où là
peut-être certaines de ces équipes
auront une chance ensuite dans une
compétition qui sera un petit peu moins
relevé forcément
honnêtement effectivement on ne sait pas
grand chose sur sur tiraspol ce n'est
pas le club le plus populaire mais il
faut toujours se méfier on reste en
ligue des champions c'est le petit
poucet de cette proposition on nous
demande c'est quand le tirage quand
est-ce que ça commence
voilà est bas et en ce moment il ya
michael essien qui en train de parler
ancienne légende de lyon de chelsea qui
en train de parler à les trades le
tirage au sort n'a toujours pas débuté
on vous a dit 18h23 ils font un peu
durer le suspense mais normalement ça va
commencer ça devrait aller assez vite on
vous a prévenu ça va durer jusqu'à au
moins 19 heures normalement mais bon
n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos questions
en attendant nous on vous prend nous on
prend vos réponses et on continue d'y
répondre sur quel club
misez vous personnellement en tant que
journaliste
les prévisions les pronostics cetc c'est
rarement bon signe oui surtout en août
pour une condition qui va se terminer
début juin c'est très compliqué
c'est une équipe sur laquelle il fallait
vraiment misé sur le papier c'est sûr
que le psg est très impressionnant mais
on n'a même pas encore vu jouer lionel
messi ou neymar cette saison donc ça me
paraît impossible aujourd'hui de se dire
que qu'ils sont favoris sur les équipes
les mieux rodé
chelsea style bayen sont un peu plus
rodés parce qu'ils ont moins évolué
durant durant le mercato
une équipe qui conserve son titre
finalement ligue des champions c'est
quand même assez rare on aime le real
madrid évidemment trois fois de suite
donc c'est je n'ose pas forcément misé
sur chelsea on pourrait dire que c'est
un peu l'année pour city
c'est quelque chose qu'on se dit depuis
cinq ans mais en même temps il va
falloir arriver un jour ça fait ils ont
joué leur première finale l'année
dernière on se dit que si c'est leur
année ça pour être maintenant on a
clairement le roi qui me dit aucun
suspense pour cette ligue des champions
bah moi je trouve pas non plus on a
quand même des énormes l'équipe moi
personnellement je vais vraiment pas
mouillé je suis désolé parce
qu'effectivement il ya des très grosses
équipes paris forcément le bayern qui
est toujours une énorme une énorme
machine alors bien de voir ben maxwell
dans le
doublage oublié l'existence on a
tellement qui nous dit qu'il met une
petite piécette sur benfica alors je pas
si c'est parce qu'ils les supporters du
benfica
s'ils croient vraiment benfica pareil
c'est ces deux-là outsiders oui c'est
vraiment du cider plus nous serrer leur
plus niveau enise que le niveau niveau
sévit ou atalanta pour le coup bien plus
quand ils sont passés par par les
barrages on le rappelle c'est une équipe
l'année dernière qui s'est fait sortir
dès les 16e de finale en ligue europa
alors qu'ils sont tombés sur arsenal
s'était pas évidemment l'équipe la plus
facile effectivement ça fait partie de
ces équipes qui risquent surtout de
s'accrocher pour jouer une ligue europa
pour jouer une troisième place alors je
veux bien me dit paris barça bayern
juventus la juventus on n'a pas encore
beaucoup parler mais la juventus alors
comme vous pour vous pouvez remarquer le
logo n'est pas le bon c'est l'ancien
logo mais bon on fera avec la juventus
n'est plus aussi forte qu'avant
elle sort d'une saison très compliqué je
moi je j'ai regardé aujourd'hui déjà il
doit sa doit sa qualification annuler
dernière journée de nappes contre
lecompte contre un petit club de l'as
vérone ils vont pas arriver de très très
serein dans cette ligue des champions
non du tout et surtout aujourd'hui on a
encore vu dans la presse les rumeurs
s'affolent et autour de l'avenir de
cristiano ronaldo on se rappelle que la
juventus et avait fait finale en 2015
finale en 2017 on se disait que
cristiano ronaldo lorsqu'il arrive en
2018 que c'est peut-être là le chaînon
manquant qui va faire passer le cap à
celle juventus ça absolument pas été le
cas puisque ils sont fait sortir en
huitième de finale la saison dernière
par le fc porto alors qu'il était quand
même archi favoris on peut lui dire
clairement la juventus oui à la haye la
grâce à sergio oliveira ancien joueur du
fc nantes exact et effectivement la
juventus elle a un petit peu régressé
aujourd'hui à la faille ne pas refaire
la ligue des champions cristiano ronaldo
a l'air vraiment sur le départ en tout
cas il a plus l'air très satisfaits ici
il y avait eu l'air massimiliano allegri
avec les deux finales depuis ils ont eu
mauricio série qui n'a fait qu'un an
andrea pirlo qui n'a fait qu'un an ils
ont rappelé allegri il ya un côté un
petit peu crise à la juventus un peu
comme on peut avoir au barça notamment
effectivement la juventus aujourd'hui
est clairement dans le dans le rang
numéro 2 on va dire s'il fallait
désigner des favoris pour la ligue des
champions alexandre qui le dit que
chelsea peuvent faire le doublé cette
année ils ont fait le recrutement pour
effectivement ils ont recruté romelu
lukaku de l'hymne terre et ça a l'air de
pas trop mal marché jusque là alors une
fois de plus on est quand doute bien sûr
on est con en août donc on va attendre
on va attendre un petit peu mais
jusqu'ici on a envie de dire que tout
roule pour thomas stovell à chelsea
lorsqu'il arrivait en janvier il s'est
très vite adapté cette victoire en ligue
des champions il a eu de bons parcours
en première ligne est en effet coeur
pour ils ont été battus en finale par
leicester sur ce début de saison tout
leur réussit ils ont reporté aussi la
supercoupe d'europe oui chelsea va faire
partie des favoris naturels c'est normal
leur mercato a l'air aussi plutôt une
réussite
oui chelsea ils ont l'air encore très
forts sur le papier et ils ont surtout
déjà l'air prêt mais encore une fois il
faut être prêt plus tôt dans six sept
mois c'est pas maintenant qu'il est
important d'être prêt alors que pendant
ce temps là pendant là excusez moi
pendant la cérémonie c'est edouard mendy
qui ont gagné le titre de meilleur
gardien de la saison en champion's
league à mon avis ils vont leur donner
les awards au enfin les récompenses au
fur et à mesure et les faire réagir on
espère que ça prendra pas trop de temps
sur le tirage au sort pour pas rester
pendant deux heures mais bon normalement
ça devrait aller on a vu une bonne
question de vielles qui nous demandent
est ce qui est du suspense jusqu'aux
quarts de finale où est ce qu'on sait à
quel point c'est un peu toujours les
mêmes équipes qui arrivent en quart de
finale finalement ou est-ce que cette
année ça peut quand même beaucoup changé
oui alors effectivement c'est un peu
toujours les mêmes gros clubs surtout
les clubs des quatre grands championnats
donc allemagne angleterre espagne italie
je crois même c'était en 2020 ou en 2021
je sais plus qu'il n'y avait que des
clubs des cinq premiers championnats ce
qui était pas loin d'être une première
effectivement sur les identités des
quarts de finalistes généralement il n'y
a pas beaucoup de suspense on peut
encore avoir des surprises on en avait
une en 2019 avec l'ajax qui était allé
jusqu'en demi finale donc ça peut encore
arriver mais oui l'eau on a beau bien
sûr on a eu un monaco aussi qu' aller
très loin on peut toujours avoir des
surprises on avait eu l'atalanta qui
avait dépassé tout proche d'une
demi-finale d'abc ch qui est elle en
quarts de finale qui était pas loin du
dernier carré aussi on peut avoir des
surprises mais là aussi encore les
surprises c'est quand même des clubs qui
commence à être assez rompus à ces
compétitions qui prennent beaucoup de
place dans leur championnat c'est des
surprises finalement assez relative oui
effectivement il n'aura que une ou deux
on peut pas imaginer que tous les
équipes du chapeau et chapeau 2 se fasse
au regard des amendes et des groupes il
y aura toujours deux ou trois surprise
mêlée mais les gros clubs restent les
gros clubs c'est quand même aussi des
questions de budget de relation les gros
clubs restent souvent top on a blank a
kind qui nous dit que les équipes plus
dans le reste reste côté anglais
justement est ce que on a une espèce de
je sais pas comment appeler ça mais est
ce qu'il ya un pays qui est favori au
togo en équipe on va dire en groupe ben
là effectivement on a cité tout à
l'heure les favoris dont pour moi plutôt
chelsea city bat yam paribas ya deux
clubs anglais
derrière dans le chapeau 2 je pense que
les deux équipes qui sortent un petit
peu du lot c'est liverpool et manchester
united oui ces clubs anglais là semble
très très armés les clubs espagnols sont
quand même légèrement crançot tout cas
le bars elle réellement sont plus ce
qu'ils étaient c'est un peu à l'image de
la liga qui a pas mal régressé ces
dernières années même si l'atletico on
l'a quasiment pas mentionné pour
l'instant l'atletico il faudra vraiment
compter sur eux je pense parce que c'est
une équipe qui est toujours présent qui
est toujours difficile à manoeuvrer
maintenant sur les clubs italiens pour
pour continuer là dans les clubs
italiens procès paraissent aussi et
quand même un cran en dessous parce
qu'on a une juventus qui est assez en
crise l'inter aussi qu'il ya beaucoup ce
couvert cet été avec les départs
d'antonio conte et et de romelu lukaku
effectivement s'il ya s'il ya un pays
qui sort du lot aujourd'hui c'est quand
même clairement l'angleterre
alors le on nous demande quand est ce
que le tirage au sort comme ans il va il
va débuter on n'a pas les images vont
pas vous montrer les images puis que
c'est des images qui appartiennent à
l'uefa et nous ne sommes pas diffuseur
mais les ça va débuter ils sont encore
un peu dans la cérémonie mais là tout le
monde s'est mis en face d'eux des boules
à tirer et ça devrait pas tarder à
commencer on à blanca qui nous demandent
à la un petit peu de mercato un avis sur
le vent de ski à la place de mvp est ce
que c'est vraiment réaliste
pas vraiment on va pas on va pas se
mentir en tout cas ça vous prend pas du
tout cette direction dans les dernières
rumeurs il ya une petite rumeur d'un
départ de lewandowski qui auraient envie
de nouveau défi loin du bayern munich
parce qu'il joue depuis un moment il a
absolument tout gagné il a tout fait il
a fait tomber beaucoup de records fonds
pourrait comprendre qu'il envie d'un
nouveau défi mais ça prend pas du tout
le sens d'un départ là maintenant ça
serait
un choc absolu je pense pour le bayern
munich de perdre dans les dernières
heures du mercato venu de nulle part son
meilleur joueur son meilleur attaquant
ça serait une énorme surprise le psg a
pas du tout l'air sur ce dossier en tout
cas pour pour cet été on pourra en
reparler plus tard lewandowski
contrairement à d'autres gros joueurs
comme ronaldo comme bape et comme pogba
il n'est pas en vain de contrat ce qui
change beaucoup de choses généralement
les joueurs en fin de contrat on les
voit souvent un petit peu sur le départ
c'est pas que les ventes de skis l'un
deux filles sauf énorme surprise jouera
bien au bayern munich cette saison alors
on à une question sur porto est ce que
porto a une chance d'aller loin tant par
les toits comme un possible outsider oui
ça fait peut-être partie de ces équipes
qu'on peut catégoriser comme outsider
qui font partie d un des plus gros
outsider justement ils sont allés en
quarts de finale l'an dernier alors
qu'ils sont ont été clairement maîtrisé
par par chelsea longchair et fait
trembler mais en huitièmes de finale ils
sortent la juventus plutôt avec la
manière même si on peut encore une fois
critiqué la juventus et un certain
déclin à la juve porto ça fait partie
des équipes quand même assez sérieuse
qui ont pas trop souffert sur le mercato
qui seront encore au rendez vous en tout
cas surtout pour taquiner en phase de
poules ça c'est clair ça fait pas partie
des équipes que les équipes du chapeau 1
et 2 ont très envie de tirer je pense on
nous demande encore sur paris est ce qu
est ce que le projet de paris peut
fonctionner dès cette année bien sûr
qu'il peut fonctionner dès cette année
ça peut aller très très vite et le
meilleur exemple c'est le plus récent
c'est celle ci avec des joueurs qui sont
arrivés pour pas mal d'entre eux l'été
qui a précédé thomas stovell qui arrive
en janvier et qui s'adapte immédiatement
et qui construit très vite un onze de
départ est une équipe en mesure d'aller
au bout oui ça peut marcher tout de
suite ils ont une équipe sur le papier
qui fait rêver on en parle un peu d'une
équipe d'une équipe all stars oui ça
peut tout à fait aller au bout ça fait
clairement partie des prétendants au
titre cette saison alors normalement le
là ils sont en train d'expliquer comment
va se passer le tirage les modalités
tout ce qu'on vous expliquer tout à
l'heure le que le fait que le zénith et
le shakhtar donetsk ne peuvent pas
tomber ensemble
ronaldo au psg est ce que vous y croyez
une autre question est qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de ronaldo qui prend la
place d'agüero à city on va faire un
petit on va englober un petit truc sur
ronaldo alors on a le dos c'est vrai
qu'il ya beaucoup de rumeurs aujourd'hui
qui sont à ma la folie
ronaldo à manchester city c'est vrai que
de prime abord il ya quand même un côté
qui sonne un petit peu faux au delà du
passif de ronaldo à manchester united
qui avait avec qui il avait eu une
excellente relation sur le jeu sur
l'aspect du jeu c'est à dire que
cristiano ronaldo sera entraînée par pep
guardiola
qui a toujours été le rival du real
madrid lorsqu'on ados joue au real
qu'est-ce qu'il entraînait le barça qui
a une façon de gérer ses équipes de les
faire jouer ne correspond pas vraiment
au jeu de ronaldo qui est un joueur
aujourd'hui à 36 ans qui est vraiment un
pur avant centre
on participe à beaucoup au jeu c'est pas
vraiment ce que recherche généralement
guardiola même avec ses avant centres ça
paraît assez assez étrange sur le papier
si on voyait au psg
c'est aussi très compliqué de l'imaginer
avec messi et neymar il va falloir
défendre nous avons dans cette équipe la
bande haut niveau à part défendre
effectivement il va falloir aussi ne pas
se marcher sur les pieds en attaque et
que ça s'applique entre les joueurs
effectivement ronaldo sur le départ
c'est s'affole un petit peu tout le
monde quoi qu'il arrive ça m'a dit 'ça
va attiser la curiosité je pense alors
naviguer qui nous pose une bonne
question pourquoi j'ai l'impression
systématiquement que les clubs français
se battent une saison pour être en
europe et puis s'en foutent une fois
qu'ils sont en coupe uefa est-ce que
vous avez cette impression alors si pour
le coup on fait référence à lille je
pense que c'est pas le meilleur exemple
aujourd'hui il y avait de meilleur
exemple en tout cas en ligue europa sur
les clubs effectivement qui se battent
pour jouer la coupe d'europe mais qui
n'apprennent ne la joue pas forcément
font parfois un petit peu tourné parce
qu'il donne la priorité au championnat
et c'est un peu le serpent qui se mord
la queue parce qu'il se donne la
priorité pour championnat pour se
qualifier pour une coupe d'europe mais
en même temps il la rejoue pas derrière
donc c'est un peu compliqué la ligne
c'est un cas un petit peu différent ils
ont perdu leur entraîneur ils ont perdu
quelques joueurs ils ont plus vraiment
le la même équipe le même noyau
je pense que en ligue des champions
c'est clairement la marche trop haute
pour eux ce serait un peu comme reproché
à rennes la saison dernière de ne pas
vraiment avoir joué la ligue des
champions qu'ils ont joués en plus pour
le coup mais à un moment donné il était
beaucoup trop limité pour pour un tel
niveau il faut aussi rappeler que comme
des enjeux financiers à se qualifier en
coupe d'europe parce que des clubs fonde
ont des gains énormes quand et arrive à
se qualifier oui tout à fait surtout sur
la ligue des champions la différence de
gains entre se qualifier pour la ligue
des champions et la ligue europa c'est
assez colossal surtout pour pour des
clubs un petit peu moindre en tout cas
comme peut l'être lille à rennes qui
n'ont pas forcément le budget d'un psg
ou d'un chelsea effectivement pour eux
une qualification en ligue des champions
c'est vraiment pas rien financièrement
alors je pense que le tirage devrait pas
tarder à commencer là on est en train de
présenter les différentes équipes du
chapeau a alors cédé on les présente en
cinq secondes à là on est en train de
voir manchester city on a eu celle
signée villarreal là ces dignitaires on
nous pose une question sur deux pailles
est-ce que de paille pour être le
meilleur buteur de ligue des champions
et qui sinon pour être ce meilleur
buteur le meilleur buteur effectivement
là on va voir on va avoir le choix des
pailles c'est plutôt intéressant parce
qu'il prend vraiment un leadership pour
l'instant au fc barcelone maintenant
faut quand même allé assez loin dans la
compétition ça n'a pas l'air d'être le
cas pour l'instant pour le pour le barça
qui peut quand même être à prétendre aux
quarts de finale mais au delà ça peut
être compliqué je pense que s'il ya un
joueur qui peut être aujourd'hui déjà
prétendants c'est erding hollande à
dortmund si je dis pas de bêtises il n'a
peut-être pas été meilleur buteur la
saison dernière mais il n'a pas été aidé
en a vraiment été très très proches
dortmund qui aujourd'hui plus en plus
sérieux qui font un quart de finale l'an
dernier on peut aussi citer la tacc les
attaquants du psg évidemment messi
neymar mbappé et on va se partager
débute exactement va avoir un petit peu
ce côté se partager les buts on peut
citer lukaku à chelsea j'ai ainsi qu'un
prétendant au titre moi je sers city on
verra si cristiano ronaldo arrive
évidemment il sera un prétendant à c'est
assez naturel voilà un petit peu pour
pour les noms ronaldo nous caf ou
peut-être bape et messi neymar et aline
gowland je pense que c'est un petit peu
les joueurs qui sortent du lot pour le
titre de meilleur buteur on a fait le
pic de mauvaise que ronaldo pourrait
faire son retour au sporting ce nouveau
salaire ça risque d'être compliqué oui
niveau financier c'est compliqué on a
dit que la clarification ligue des
champions ramène de l'argent sans rien a
encore haussé au sporting pour se
qualifier pour recruter ronaldo pardon
ronaldo sporting donc franchement
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on n'y croit pas
du tout clairement ça valait vraiment
d'être la juventus au city à moins que
le psg fasse un coup sensationnel en
vendant 2 bat p et en rachetant la donne
dans la foulée mais ça n'en prend pas
trop au schéma donc le cas le genre
vient de commencer alors on vous le
rappelle là on va tirer d'abord les
les équipes du chapeau 1 donc l'atletico
chelsea bayern lignes ter lille
manchester city villarreal et le
sporting et les mettre dans leur groupe
respectif là c'est city qui est tombé
dans le chapeau 1 dans le groupe ah
pardon excusez moi
deuxième groupe tirée c'est l'atletico
madrid qui sera dans le groupe b mais
bon là on va continuer à prendre
vocation parce que c'est pas encore le
moment où ça va être intéressant
est ce que est ce que lille va faire un
choix finalement on nous demande en
fonction du tirage de jouer ou pas cette
ligue des champions ils peuvent
peut-être peut-être faire un choix après
ça dépendra aussi de de la façon dont
est géré le calendrier de certaines
blessures dans certains états de forme
maintenant lille je pense que clairement
leurs ambitions ils vont peut-être pas
le dire le dire clairement mais leur
ambition maximum ces deux une troisième
place pour jouer pour jouer la ligue
europa on verra le tirage encore une
fois mais on a vu que dans le chapeau à
est dans le chapeau dans le chapeau 1 et
dans le chapeau 2 il ya vraiment que des
cadors quasiment que des équipes qui
sont prétendants ou pas loin d'être
prétendre au titre pour lille clairement
l'ambition elle va être de jouer la
ligue europa et même ça je pense que la
priorité au championnat risque d'être un
petit peu donné alors que le sporting
était tirée d'un groupe c'est l'inter de
milan est retirée dans le groupe d on à
florian qui me dit karim benzema hasard
belle mba p s'il vient au real ça
pourrait faire du mal adversaire oui
c'est bien d'avoir une belle attaque
mais oui voilà effectivement il n'y aura
pas il y aura pas il n'y aura pas que
cette attaque on verra aussi comment
aider nazar se sentira toute la saison
parce qu'il a vécu pour l'ensemble de
année vraiment galère au real
effectivement si mbappé signe au real
madrid a d'un coup ça les fait un petit
peu monté d'un petit cran quand même
même s'il faudra peut-être un suppôt du
temps aussi l'adaptation verra on verra
il yad'autres d'autres secteurs de jeu
que le don le real doit peut-être
s'inquiéter
effectivement ça permettrait de les
prendre un petit peu plus au sérieux
dans la victoire finale mais je suis pas
sûr que même avec ça même avec le bape
et le real se retrouveraient vraiment
dans ce gotha du bayern city chelsea
paris des vrais prétendants au titre
alors dans le groupe e c'est le bayern
munich qui vient juste d'être tirés jl
dit franchement lille peut et doit même
terminé troisièmes vu lé pot 3 et 4 oui
mais ça peut être compliqué surtout
qu'on l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est quand
même c'est quand même l'équipe qui a le
moins de poids au coefficient uefa
exactement oui même moins que tiraspol
qui est qui joue sa première ligue des
champions donc ça c'est en dit long sur
le passif européen et ça aussi on n'en a
pas beaucoup parlé mais l'expérience est
évidemment très important dans les
compétitions européennes alors il ya des
joueurs qui ont un petit peu de vécu à
lille droite l'image des fontes
effectivement ils ont ils en ont du vécu
pour le coup mais en coupe d'europe ce
groupe n'a quasiment aucune expérience
si ce n'est la saison dernière
finalement où ils ont fait un seizième
de finale de ligue europa ils ont
éliminé par l'ajax
lille franchement il parle quand même de
très très loin on verra selon le tirage
sur le papier
s'ils peuvent s'il doit vraiment
prétendre à une troisième place mais
c'est vraiment leur plafond je pense
alors que toutes les équipes du chapeau
1 viennent d'être retirés montluçon
citigroup a dit qu madrid groupe b
sporting portugal groupe c 1 termine un
groupe d bayern munich groupe e
villarreal groupe f et lille groupe g et
chelsea groupe h et alors c'est
maintenant que ça commence à être
intéressant on va avoir une autre des
autres équipes alors que pendant ce
temps là le l'uefa nous nous donne le
défenseur sait pas si c'est si c'est une
équipe qui défend où tous les défenseurs
en tout cas ce sera robben dias qui ce
qui est élu défenseur de l'année en
champion's league robben dias qui venait
d'arriver à city et qui a fait une
saison absolument incroyable oui
incroyable il a même été élu meilleur
joueur de premier league je crois même
pas meilleur défenseur le meilleur
joueur c'est vraiment dire à quel point
son adaptation était et est réussie
c'est aujourd'hui l'un des tous
meilleurs défenseurs du monde il s'est
déjà installé en tant que tel c'est un
joueur qui a une personnalité
exceptionnelle et c'est aussi ce qui
explique qu'ils soient adaptés aussi
vite à city qu'ils soient déjà capable
de prendre un certain leadership à city
oui pour le coup robin dias il a été
énorme malheureusement ça n'a pas tourné
en faveur de city en finale contre
chelsea mais lui c'est vraiment pas un
des joueurs qui a quelque chose à se
reprocher alors que c'est irène paredes
qui a gagné le titre de meilleure
joueuse
pendant l'uefa champion's league
féminine on nous demande est ce que si
le psg gagne ligue des champions la
france peut monter cinquième au
coefficient uefa on y est déjà 5e il
faut juste pas tombé au delà c'est ça
alors non non non
maintenant justement on est descendu en
dessous en dessous du portugal notamment
l'élimination de monaco qui n'a pas aidé
alors que mme efficace et qualifié pour
le court en ligue des champions
effectivement si le psg gagne la ligue
des champions ça a fait remarquer
énormément de points pour la france au
coefficient uefa
maintenant je ne connais pas les
spécificités mathématiques je sais pas
comment si ça peut suffire vraiment ça
va dépendre évidemment du parcours de
lille nature à l'aviron pas aussi
exactement il n'y aura pas on retrouvera
notamment lyon peut-être lille donc en
l'occurrence et on verra aussi les
parcours des clubs portugais on a dit
que porto est peut-être un outsider il
peut peut espérer un huitième un quart
de finale on verra si benfica sort de
son groupe le sporting aussi al'avantage
d'être dans le chapeau 1 donc a priori
d'avoir un tirage un peu plus abordable
c'est aussi des équipes qui si elle se
retrouve en ligue europa là peuvent
devenir de gros outsiders voir des prêts
des prétendants au titre on à alexandre
qui nous parle de manchester united
ovules leur recrutement ont-ils une
chance d'atteindre le dernier carré on
n'a pas trop parlé manchester united
mais c'est vrai que ça peut ça peut
marcher ont ils ont parfois quand même
un peu de mal bien sûr c'est une équipe
je trouve qu'il ya pas mal progressé qui
prend vraiment le bon chemin cet été sur
le recrutement on peut en parler raphaël
varane c'est une excellente recrue
évidemment l'idée pour surtout pour la
ligue des champions avec tout son vécu
jalonnent seul show très bien sur le
papier c'est vraiment c'est très costaud
à dortmund s'était imposé comme un top
top joueur oui manchester united je
pense que ça fait partie justement de
ceux de se rendre numéro 2 on peut
retrouver united liverpool peut-être
l'atletico de ses équipes vraiment
qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent se glisser en
tout cas parmi le dernier carré et
peut-être jouer leurs chances pour la
victoire finale alors
nous demande petit point joueur est ce
que van dyk et plus fort que ramos un
peu plus jeunes effectivement il est
plus jeune or sur la saison dernière
évidemment on n'a pas le temps ramos
aussi a été pas mal en difficulté il a
quasiment pas joué de la fin de saison
parce qu'il était blessé
aujourd'hui serge et devant nice ça fait
ça fait quand même sur le jeu on a envie
de dire que oui van dyke aujourd'hui si
on doit faire un classement mais très au
dessus même si c'est ça reste assez
vague évidemment sur un match on sait
jamais ce qu'il peut se passer mais
wanda que c'était un prétendant au
ballon d'or il ya pas si longtemps ce
que n'était plus vraiment ramos
maintenant sur un match sur une double
confrontation à voir sergio ramos de son
équipe je pense qu'aujourd'hui même
encore aujourd'hui il vaut mieux l'avoir
avec soi que contre soi ça reste un
joueur solide expérimenté qui connaît ce
contexte ligue des champions maintenant
si si si on a un club qui peut recruter
l'un des deux je pense que clairement il
recrute van dijk alors pendant ce temps
là on nous demande quand est-ce qu'on
aura lieu le tirage au sort de la ligue
europa il aura lieu de demain à midi
puisqu'il est encore des équipes qui
jouent les barrages ce soir et le ça
commence au niveau du groupe 2 donc on
est en train de sortir la première
équipe de la poule b il faut pas oublier
ces mines ont bien évidemment le
borussia dortmund de broxeele d'hormones
qui est la première équipe ya des tirs
et donc le borussia dortmund qui ne
pourra pas jouer contre le bayern munich
on ne peut pas avoir deux équipes du
même pays en toi et puis même nom en
fait tu
attendais parce que je suis entrain de 2
c'est qu'en fait il faut qu'il soit dans
le dans l'équipe opposée je crois qu'ils
avaient une histoire comme ça aussi
lewis laissera côté des cas de l'autre
exactement parce que notamment alors je
crois que c'est surtout en relation avec
les droits télés les soirs où sont re
dit on sont diffusés les matches selon
mardi et mercredi ne pas avoir tous les
passants quatre clubs anglais qui joue
le mardi soir ça ça embête un petit peu
les télés et donc le ils seront dans le
groupe c dortmund sera dans le groupe c
un groupe s'est du coup avec dortmund et
le sporting dortmund a peut-être tiré le
gros lot déjà oui un petit peu ils ont
peut-être ils ont peut-être l'équipe la
plus faible sur le papier en tout cas
avec lille ville que je mettrais quand
même un cran en dessous du sporting
c'est plutôt un tirage assez favorable
pour dortmund qui qui espèrent se
qualifier qui fait pas partie non plus
des favoris pour se qualifier deuxième
équipe tirait c'est le real madrid à
l'instant le el madrid comme qu'on l'a
dit avec une année assez compliqué ils
n'ont pas gagné la coupe est pleine et
le titre ramos qui s'en va ramos qui
était le symbole de ce sera dinde reid
ça va être compliqué pour eux oui ça
reste compliqué pour eux cette année je
pense que comme on l'a dit il faut à
peine parti de sorensen numéro deux dé
en juste en dessous des favoris
maintenant évidemment si les
recrutements de me battais ça peu un
petit peu chamboulé quelques quelques
petites choses alors le real madrid ils
seront dans ces michael essien qui est
en train de dévisser la boule pour
savoir dans quel groupe ils vont arriver
ce sera le groupe d pour le real madrid
un petit inter de milan real madrid
c'est déjà pas mal moi je me demande si
ce n'était pas déjà le cas la saison
dernière d'ailleurs c'était déjà le cas
et avec le shaq avec le shakhtar donetsk
exactement vrai et unitaire qui avait
fini dernier de son groupe et ça ça a
été une grosse surprise et ça avait
failli coûter son poste à antonio conte
et qu'ils avaient été maintenus derrière
il était champion d'italie donc c'est
pas mal à rattraper
c'est pas le pire tirage je pense pour
le real madrid parce que comme on l'a
dit ginter s'est un peu affaibli cet été
a priori effectivement voilà le favori
de ce groupe pour l'instant je travaille
ça devrait le rester c'est le real
madrid c'est liverpool qui vient d'être
équipe qui va être tiré au sort on nous
demande juste assez rapidement comment
trouvez-vous griffes d'un petit avis sur
deux sur ceux des riches que je n'ai pas
joué mais encore sur cette algue riches
alors personnellement je n'ai pas encore
vu jouer en tout cas avec les reflex
city mais avec avec aston villa il a été
a été exceptionnel ça fait partie des
mets tout le meilleur de premier league
à son poste milieu offensif voire
presque presque attaquant c'était un
leader absolu beaucoup de gens voulaient
le voir maintenant dans une grosse
équipe même si c'est pas très sexy sur
le côté loyauté envers aston villa mais
effectivement c'est on peut être assez
impatient de le voir aujourd'hui à
manchester city square de la alors en
parlant de belles retrouvailles
liverpool va d'aller dans le groupe b
avec l'atletico madrid on se rappelle
l'atletico madrid qui avait sorti
liverpool avant le coup vide et ça avait
été c'était un peu un cataclysme oui un
petit peu et puis ça c'est quand même
assez assez équilibré pour le coup c'est
vraiment deux équipes d'un niveau de
stocks sont assez similaires un petit
peu comme comme le sporting dortmund où
pour le coup on a une équipe forte du
chapeau 2 et une équipe relativement
faible du chapeau du chapeau 1
ça va être du costaud je pense que
l'équipe qui sera lent groupe b sera pas
très contente de l'être alors on vient
de voir un magnifique gros plan sur
d'affaires elle rallie fille puisque le
psg est retiré et le psg sera avec dans
le groupe a avec manchester city on
voulait un petit on n'a pas eu à voile à
manchester city paris saint germain
voilà bah je pense que on commence déjà
à avoir un bon un bon groupe on va voir
ce qui va se passer derrière mais sait
déjà c'est déjà très costaud oui voilà
encore une fois en termes de
retrouvailles basse et la demi finale de
ligue des champions il ya quelques mois
encore c'est peut-être ce que pouvait
avoir de plus difficile le psg en tout
cas avec le bayern chelsea ça va être du
costaud d'entrée au moins ils vont
pouvoir déjà vraiment je pense se tester
sur le contexte ligue des champions on
le rappelle la vérité de la part de
saison n'est pas la même qu'en avril et
en mai c'est à ce moment là qu'il faudra
être fort le tirage au sort continue je
regarde vos commentaires si vous nous
posez des questions n'hésitez pas on
nous demande qui sera ballon d'or c'est
un peu alors on va juste regarder cette
équipe qui va être tiré parce que c'est
la juventus qui vient d'être tiré et
qu'il ira dans le groupe h je viens de
ce qui sera donc avec chelsea
chelsea juventus
pas forcément un très bon tirage sachant
qu'il restait quand même lille et
villarreal oui c'est pas c'est pas un
cadeau du tout pour pour la juge pour le
coup
chelsea qui fait clairement partie des
favoris tenant du titre du coup
ça s'annonce soit s'annonce compliquée
pour l'âge où on verra qui tire en
chapeauteront chapeau 4 c'est quand même
pas le groupe le plus fort pour
l'instant je pense que c'est assez clair
avec ce qu'on a dans ce groupe à pour
l'instant oui effectivement un peu d'ail
on a du bayern villarreal lille et là
c'est le fc barcelone qui vient d'être
tiré on va voir dans quel groupe ils
vont tomber le bas
tombez bien évidemment avec villarreal
donc ce sera soit bayern munich soit
lille il ya comme un meilleur tirage là
où l'autre pour puis effectivement c'est
pas deux équipes du même niveau entre le
bayern et hull alors michael essien nous
donner le groupe dans lequel va tomber
cette
équipe du fc barcelone sera le groupe e
donc ce sera le bayern munich le bayern
munich pour
pour le pour le fc barcelone excusez moi
avec ronald koeman qui fait la tête
devant il n'est pas forcément très ravel
mais c'est pas ça c'est vraiment un
tirage favorable s'est pacsé pas cadeau
c'est ben voilà c'est pas cadeau clément
qui la ligue des champions ça devient
merdique vite la super league s'il vous
plaît avec une ligue fermée on pouvait
pas avoir des petites équipe
macédonienne
moldave comme le tiraspol ça changerait
quand même beaucoup oui ça changerait ça
changerait beaucoup ça ferait pas ça
serait ça ressemblerait tête est
l'unique ferme et ça serait ça sera tout
autre contexte après serait un grand
débat on aime on n'aime pas mais ça
c'est un tout autre débat pour le couple
il avec ces vies comme nous le dj hell
on vient d'arriver au niveau de notre
écran lille sévit pas mal pour les
finalement on est vite on évite les très
très gros effectivement c'est peut-être
ça fait peut-être partie de ces deux
trois équipes les plus faibles entre
guillemets du chapeau 2 c'est un tirage
mais on peut pas dire abordable pour
lille parce que je pense qu'aucune de
ces équipes n'est ni abordable pour pour
le losc pour le coup c'est un tirage on
va dire relativement clément ils sont
assez épargné et manchester united du
coup qui jouera contre villarreal là
aussi une entrée en matière assez assez
sympa pour montrer sa vénalité douelle
revanche du coup delà de la finale avec
durand patrimoine très mal de de
retrouvailles
effectivement même si villarreal avait
gagné cette finale moi j'essaie un
acteur pourrait largement craindre un
pire tirage même si pour le coup oui
c'est pas être avec city pouvait pas le
fait que celle ci
ça va c'est pas le pire tirage que
pouvait avoir manchester united par
contre pas du coup dans l'autre sens
pour le coup pour villarreal s'est pas
vraiment cadeau on agit elle qui lui dit
sévices et bien on peut gratter un point
voire trois peut-être
je crois que j'arrive à l'identifier en
tant que supporters du losc
effectivement c'est un tirage qui est
assez assez favorable après ces vies
c'est quand même assez costaud en
espagne oui c'est costaud ils ont fait
ils ont été 4e en liga la saison
dernière c'est une équipe si les pas de
bêtises sont éliminés en 8e de finale de
ligue des champions la saison dernière
par dortmund qui sont tombés sur un
grand erling collante
sévit on verra aussi la fin du mercato
parce qu'il ya un joueur très important
qui risque de partir ces jeux kundé si
jamais son départ se fait de chelsea ce
départ se fait de ces vers chelsea ça
sera un gros coup dur c'est un élément
clé aujourd'hui de la défense ça reste
quand même une des équipes les plus
abordables en tout cas de ce chapeau 2
on peut le dire je pense assez assez
assez clairement mais ça reste une
équipe très sérieuse qui sera absolument
pas là par hasard et qui vise clairement
les huitièmes de finale voir les quarts
de finale de ligue des champions alors
ngolo quand tu es à la surprise générale
a été élu meilleur milieu de la toile
fait cela on s'y attendait quand même à
peu près tous
oui sur sur ces vies effectivement on
peut rappeler que jules kundé de vaud
pourrait partir à chelsea seeker zuma
est finalement transféré c'est ça alors
curieusement la danse beaucoup à west
ham sont les dernières informations il y
avait un ultime problème alors que tout
semblait fait pour le départ de zuma de
chelsea si jamais son départ ne se fait
pas ça peut tout remettre en cause pour
l'avenir de jeu le kundé rester à
séville pour rire franchement je pense
que le vivra très bien il a l'air très
bien là bas il est titulaire
indiscutable ici et panique très bien je
pense que pour lui ça resterait quand
même ça serait pas ne sert pas une si
mauvaise nouvelle que ça loin de là pour
sévir pour le coup ce serait une très
bonne nouvelle
on a beau gars qui me dit barcelone est
vraiment dans un fossé en ce moment oui
barcelone c'est plus le grand barcelone
et l'a77 cette saison quand ils vont
jouer contre le bayern munich avant
c'était un choc à 50 50 on peut plus
dire que ça l'est oui clairement on ne
peut plus on peut plus dire depuis le 8
2 en 2020 qu'on a qu'on a tous vus
depuis le bayern il avait remporté la
ligue des champions derrière on se
souvient en finale face au psg ils sont
toujours au top c'est une équipe
extrêmement extrêmement rodez même avec
leur changement d'entraîneur avec
l'arrivée de nagels man
alors à leur tête c'est fait partie des
favoris des 3/4 favori clairement le
barça est en crise je pense qu'on l'a
tous vu et surtout nous en france avec
un raid mais si on sait que le barça ne
va plus du tout le même
clairement le barça il ya il ya une
équipe clairement au dessus au dessus de
l'autre sur sur cette confrontation avec
le bayern qui est toujours aussi solides
au final en allemagne qui reste une
grosse machine et qui est toujours qu'il
quitte tout aussi impressionnante on est
en train de voir du coup les différentes
équipes du chapeau 3 en train de voir
benfica on a vu le chakhtior qui a
éliminé monaco hier l'atalante à
l'atalante a effectivement avec son jeu
toujours flamboyant on peut dire
qui toi toi tu mettais comme peut-être
là où c'est à dire principal oui en
effet parce que l'atalanta bon mais
jamais vus face au psg en quart de
finale et qui sont passés à rien des
demi finales c'est une équipe qui est
elle encore présente en ligue des
champions l'année dernière qui est
tombée sur sur le real madrid il avait
quand même fait vraiment amende
honorable je trouve sur l'ensemble des
deux confrontations
c'est une équipe qui peut qui peut être
assez sérieuse en tout cas en temps en
tant qu'outsider qui peut regarder des
grosses équipes dans les yeux en phase
finale c'est l'équipe aussi qui est
passé par quelques turbulences notamment
le départ de deux papous gomez qui était
le catalyseur de ce jeu si spectaculaire
qui est parti un peu en claquant la
porte mais c'est une équipe trouve
toujours très forte on verra quand même
dans les dernières heures du mercato si
l'on pas quelques départs c'est pas
impossible qui est parti assez vite du
coup pas qu est ce que le quelques lits
de retrouvera c'est le shaktar donesk
qui vient d'être tiré en premier
du coup nous allons voir ac dans
quelques et dans quelles poules va
tomber le shaq landesk louis kiehl ou 10
ans en tant que fan du barça j'ai peur
mondiaux le barça sans messi avec le
bayern pour moi c'est un bon test pour
le fc barcelone vous êtes un peu partagé
mais quand même vous n'êtes pas très
comment dire
vous y croyez quand même pas trop trop
on va dire alors que nous allons voir
dans quel groupe va tomber le chakhtior
donetsk on vous rappelle que le shaktar
donesk ne peut pas tomber contre des
équipes russes
donc ils vont tomber dans le groupe d ce
sera le groupe d pour le chakhtior est
bien comme on se retrouve j'ai envie de
dire à terme 1 terminant real madrid
chaque heure de naître c'est le même
groupe que l'an dernier exactement c'est
les trois équipes qui s'étaient déjà
affrontés c'est assez rare que ça se
passe que ça se passe comme ça
j'ai pas le souvenir d'un tirage au
monde a déjà mis trois alors ce qui est
bien c'est que la quatrième équipe
c'était le borussia mönchengladbach tu
sais tu n'es pas là donc on n'ira pas
jusqu'au bout mais franchement c'est
déjà assez fort et on se rappelle en
plus que le secteur avait fait de très
bons matches contre le real a fait très
beau match contre l'inter je n'ai pas
exactement touly tous les scores on
pourrait les voir là c'est le benfica
qui est ça c'est benfica qui est en
train de tirer en ce moment benchikha
qui ne propose pas tomber dans le même
groupe que le sporting donc pas de
groupes c'est pour le benfica
pas de pas de groupes c'est pour le
benfica n'hésitez pas content continue à
nous poser des questions ronaldo contre
messi toujours pareil ce vieux débat
on va déjà des matchs de demi-finale
dans les groupes oui effectivement en
fait on a l'impression que il y a quand
même des gros groupes on voit le groupe
à le groupe e même le groupe b ça pour
être des demi finales déjà le groupe d
oc web on avait dealé le groupage même
fin voilà déjà six groupes ou cinq
groupes où pourrait-on on avait dit le
chapeau 2 les très dense donc forcément
on a ce genre de confrontation alors le
benfica avait tombé avec le bayern
munich et le fc barcelone
voilà donc le benfica va devoir réussir
à tirer son épingle du jeu est ce que
benfica peut faire quelque chose alors
permis qu'on a dit ça va être quand même
très compliqué mais quand barcelone
contre barcelone forcément ils ont quand
même une petite chance parce que c'est
plus le grand barça maintenant benfica
c'est quand même une équipe qui est un
peu rentré pour se retrouver en
championnat une saison très compliquée
en championnat la saison dernière ils
ont pu se passer par les barrages et
s'est passé assez assez gris craque
c'est une équipe qui peut peut-être joué
sa chance mais s'il passe en huitièmes
honnêtement ça se ferait un peu sur un
malentendu je pense ils font clairement
pas partie des équipes qui sont là pour
absolument être en huitièmes et qui en
tout cas font partie des favoris à ce
niveau là sont quand même plutôt la
bonne tête pour l'instant de l'équipe
qui fera troisième et qui rendront
ensuite à une bonne question de john
snow est ce que le gagnant du groupe f
se verra redonner rétroactive
rétroactivement la ligue europa
puisque c'est puisque c'est les deux
finalistes en rappel de la précédente
édition effectivement alors peut-être
que je viens en a un qui rejouera la
ligue europa derrière ces problèmes de
son groupe on verra mais ces deux
équipes qui peuvent clairement postuler
officiel maintenant de finale de ligue
des champions alors que les années 2
vient de tomber avec la juventus et
chelsea donc chelsea juventus zénith un
groupe assez ouvert comme on l'a dit
puisque la juventus n'est plus aussi
sereine qu'avant oui bien sûr j'ai tout
à l'heure sur le sur le chat on
utilisait le zénith est ce que ça peut
être un petit peu un des outsiders moi
j'ai un peu du mal à y croire même si en
effet la juventus c'est une juventus
aujourd'hui relativement relativement
prenable là pour le coup si jamais ils
sortent pas des poules de ligue des
champions ça ferait un nouveau choc
après avoir été sorti en huitièmes l'an
dernier par porto là ne pas passer les
poules en se retrouvant avec le zénith
ça serait un choc mais effectivement
c'est une équipe qui peut jouer sa
chance alors que là c'est de la psyché
qui vient d'être tiré on voir dans quel
groupe ils ont deux chances sur quatre
de tomber avec un club français
puisqu'ils ne peuvent pas jouer dans le
groupe c contre dortmund et sera groupe
a donc nous serons avec manchester city
paris saint germain et l'a86 ch
on commence à ressembler commence à
ressembler vraiment un groupe de la mort
cette histoire mais là ça commence à
être très dense si je dis pas de bêtises
bas la saison dernière déjà le psg les
psych s'étaient affrontées en phase de
groupes on avait vu que pour le psg ça
avait été très très compliqué notamment
au parc des princes où il avait été
archi-dominés il s'en était sorti sur un
penalty de neymar je crois c'est pas un
cadeau pour pour pour le psg tout alors
je disais que ça peut être bien de jouer
des grosses équipes pour un peu ce
vraiment se tester parce que ça peut
ressembler à une phase d'échauffement
pour des équipes aussi fortes en ligue
des champions
là ça sera peut-être pas tant que
l'échauffement que ça parce que là il va
quand même falloir un peu rassuré parce
que les psych clairement s'ils sont là
c'est pour jouer les huitièmes de finale
et est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas déjà dans
ce groupe à un bon favori pour la ligue
europa ce cela qui se fera sortir et
qu'il arrivera troisième en ligue europa
personne ne voudra jouer derrière je
pense en ligue europa a priori alors que
le tirage au sort continue on va voir
kiss quittera cette 3ème équipe qui
vient de tomber dans le groupe f alors
j'ai pas vu le nom de l'équipe juste
avant dans le groupe f nous aurons donc
l'atalanta donc villarreal manchester
united atalanta et ce groupe là moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est assez c'est quand
même très ouvert c'est pas d'essai pas
des grands cadors et cd the outsider
plus on va dire oui c'est un salaire
d'un groupe quand même assez assez
homogène pour le coup on l'a dit
atalanta ça fait deux saisons je crois
qu'ils sont en huitième de finale de
ligue des champions la saison dernière
qui s'arrêtent justement lui tiennent
face au real madrid juste au dessus de
la sur le visuel on voit qu'on a les
deux finalistes de ligue europa qui sont
des prétendants sérieux pour jouer la
finale la phase finale de la ligue des
champions
effectivement ça va être un groupe quand
même très serré ça va être je pense
assez excitant à voir nous allons voir
et qui va tomber cette bourde ça ce
bourg qui tombe avec lille lille salvo
séville alain verte on commence à
peut-être commencé on peut couper être
commencer à y croire pour lille si si la
campagne se passe bien ça peut aller
loin ouais ouais on est faible en tout
cas moi personnellement c'est sévices
étaient peut-être l'équipe pour moi la
plus la moins forte on va dire du
chapeau 2 sél salsbourg que ça m'a l'air
d'être pareil pour le pour le chapeau 3
je pense que lille pouvait difficilement
avoir un tirage plus favorable en tout
cas plus abordable
effectivement sur le papier on se dit qu
entre lille et ces vies et sas bourgue
ya pas un écart si monstrueux en tout
cas du point de vue du losc comme une
vielle le groupe g est jouable avec
cellier salzbourg en tout cas il y avait
pire ça c'est vrai qu'hier après tu peux
encore retour trouvé que le mag le milan
mais c'est toujours pas le grand milan
et ça reste assez assez jouable pensa le
fc porto est tombé dans le groupe d avec
l'atletico madrid et liverpool voilà là
aussi ça va être assez compliqué pour le
fc porto ouais effectivement alors on en
parlait d'un comme tabous comme d'un
outsider voir un gros outsider
l'atletico et liverpool c'est pas cadeau
du tout ce sont deux prétendants de
prétendant aux demi finales voire à plus
effectivement sait pas garder pour porto
mais c'est pas cadeau non plus pour
l'atletico et pour liverpool du coup ce
sont trois équipes qui étaient en
huitièmes de finale l'année dernière
qui n'ont pas fait de cas si je ne
m'abuse je crois que l'atletico s'est
fait sortir par liverpool justement en
huitième
mais ce sont trois équipes qui
clairement candidate à la phase finale
alors on nous dit que villa elle ne
prend qu'un seul r il me semble qu
effectivement tendance à homps en
première de 122 me je viens de vérifier
désolé c'est en prenant deux pendant ce
temps là du coup hurling allende a été
élu meilleur attaquant de l'as de la
phase 2 de la champion's league de l'an
dernier le norvégien henning allende r
line galante qui va retrouver du coup
l'ajax d'amsterdam et le sporting ce
groupe c'est aussi il est quand même
assez light on va dire oui oui
effectivement il n'est pas un peu comme
le com le groupe g pour pour lille
effectivement on parlait du groupe d
du chapeau 4 pardon avec l'ac milan si
on a la semitan dans le groupe c où dans
le rouge et on pourra dire que le milan
a une chance quand même assez sérieuse
finalement de jouer la phase finale avec
des champions ce qui serait quelque
chose d'assez incroyable quand on
repense on était le milan il ya un ou
deux ans où il était vraiment loin de la
ligue des champions il est loin d'y
penser alors encore plus les huitièmes
de finale
aujourd'hui si le milan se retrouve dans
la serre ou plat il pourrait presque
faire office de favori du groupe ou pas
loin effectivement le milan qui est là
c'est milan qui est la plus grosse
équipe de ce chapeau 4 le tirage au sort
va commencer alors d'ailleurs ling
allende qui nous fait un petit discours
pour nous dire qu'il est très content de
son prix
du coup on a quand même le groupe à là
pour l'instant en terme de groupe de la
mort le groupe a c'est quand même le
plus gros groupe on a l'impression il ya
le groupe béké pas mal aussi quand même
le groupe b oui qui est pas mal moi j'ai
envie de dire que le groupe 1 s'il avait
fallu désigner une équipe l'équipe la
plus forte pour chaque chapeau je pense
que ça aurait ressemblé à ça pour
l'instant
je pense que je pense que oui là on est
clairement sur une appellation de le
groupe de la mort avec le groupe b donc
atletico madrid liverpool porto groupe c
sporting dortmund ajax groupe des
intermittents real madrid shakhtar john
yates groupe e munich barcelone benfica
groupe f villarreal manchester united
atalanta bergame groupe g lille sévices
salzburg groupage chelsea juventus la
juventus pardon et le zenit saint
pétersbourg moi ce groupe f là il me
plaît aussi pas mal quand même parce que
c'est ça ça va être un groupe qui est
très ouvert oui assez ouvert et puis
avec avec l'atalanta qui est quand même
généralement à ses joueuses qui en tout
cas emballez pas mal de matches en ligue
des champions ces dernières années c'est
un groupe clairement ouvert on verra qui
sera qui sera dans le quel sera l'équipe
du chapeau 4
effectivement l'équipe qui va se
retrouver en ligue europa parmi ces
trois là c'est une équipe qui aura
clairement sa chance en ligue europa si
jamais c'est l'une de ces équipes là
évidemment parce qu'il ya une quatrième
équipe avec le chapeau 4 effectivement
là on est en train de voir les équipes
du chapeau 4 on demandait justement qui
sont les faibles du chapeau 4 il ya
malmö il ya tiraspol il ya bruges il ya
les young boys de berne c'est ça c'est
des équipes qui dans tous les cas ça va
pas être pas ils sont programmés pour
cette quatrième place mais s'il faut
mieux ce serait vraiment très forts de
leur part oui ce sont des équipes à part
peut-être la semitan et encore parce que
c'est une équipe qui est en tout cas un
groupe qui a peu d'expérience en coupe
d'europe même s'il ya des jours comme on
vraiment qu'il n'en manque pas
d'expérience comme ibrahimovic régis
roux on pourrait en citer pas mal
ce sont généralement des équipes dont le
plafond se trouve sur la troisième place
sur cette qualification en ligue europa
pour rester en vie dans les coupes
d'europe généralement c'est pas des
équipes qui ont pour objectif de finir
dans les deux premiers alors qu'on à
habib qui demande à ce que me lance dans
le groupe g il y décrit cinq fois
d'affilée je ne pense pas que en
écrivant cinq fois ça va changer quelque
chose mais tu peux continuer blaise qui
nous dit lille peut rêver pour une place
qualificative
effectivement le groupe de lille de
groupe g ils sévissent à ce bond pour
l'instant c'est quand même assez ouvert
bah oui clairement cesser totalement
ouvert on verra qui sera la dernière
équipe pour les accompagner mais on se
dit que pour pour jouer encore une coupe
d'europe au moins en février donc c'est
à dire dans les temps les trois premiers
du groupe pour l'instant c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas fou de d'imaginer ça alors
que c'est les young boys de berne qui
ont été tirées et du mosbah on imagine
aussi enfin on plaint quand même
l'équipe du chapeau 4 l'équipe du
chapeau 4 justement qu'il va tomber dans
le groupe a quand même oui oui
clairement je pense que je pense que son
ambition et sera assez vite revu à la
baisse malheureusement elle jouera juste
crânement sa chance on a presque envie
que ce soit que ce soit tiraspol com -
s'il joue avec des champions sera
première fois de leur histoire me
rappelle pas au moins au moins il va
nous voler un grand match ils vont
recevoir des stars ils vont vivre le
truc à fond on verra qui se sera mais
effectivement ça sera pas un cadeau du
tout c'est le groupe f du coup pour les
young boys de berne le groupe f donc
villarreal manchester united atalanta
bergame
savoir quand même il ya quand même une
classe entre ces trois équipes et les
young boys oui clairement il ya un
regain petit fossé maintenant les young
boys ça reste une équipe qui est habitué
aux coupes d'europe qui a s'est rompue à
ça même en ligue des champions les a
quand même assez souvent vu ces
dernières années or généralement ils
font pas grand chose je sais même pas
s'ils ont déjà joué en huitième de
finale de ligue des champions dans leur
histoire
maintenant c'est une équipe qui jouera
crânement sa chance mais oui un petit
fossé entre eux et les trois autres on à
gaël qui nous pose qui me dit que lille
doit acheter des joueurs car
actuellement ils sont nuls ça me paraît
un peu tranché comme la fille pour
l'instant on lui demande quand commence
la phase de poules elle commence entre
le 14 et le qu'elle commence le 14 et le
15 septembre donc le premier match ce
sera le 14 et on avait une question sur
le ballon d'or assure jean hieaux est ce
que jean vigneau peut avoir le ballon
d'or alors c'est un nom qui revient ou
pourquoi parce qu'il a tout gagné en
fait enfin il a tout gagné la ligue des
champions et le rose qui n'est pas le
cas de beaucoup jour cette année même
les années précédentes préparez demerson
aussi vous reparler désarçonne
effectivement qui avions aujourd'hui je
pense pas qu'on verra le match en lion
cette année ça pas sûr non plus qu'on
reverra chelsea georgino qui a été très
très fort avec l'italie avec chelsea
saga aucun problème j'ai l'impression
que si un joueur qui part favori il joue
au psg il s'appelle lionel messi je
pense que c'est un joueur qui part
plutôt favoris il y aura d'autres
candidats effectivement entre l'italie
chelsea voire même voire même au psg ou
un neymar un bape et sont toujours un
petit peu dans le coin je pense que si
un favori en tout cas il s'appelle
lionel messi alors que le groupe ccb
gildas qui vient de tomber dans le
groupe c'est un groupe c'est comme on
l'a dit qu'ils étaient ouverts à trois
équipes et qui est encore ouvert à
quatre équipes des chutes à ce qui peut
tout comme y croire pour arriver en 8e
de finale oui mais qui peut y croire
tout à fait parce que le sporting on a
dit c'est une des équipes les plus
faibles avec l'île du chapeau 1 c'est
une équipe qui n'a aucune expérience en
ligue des champions voire même en coupe
d'europe ont comme on l'a dit l'année
dernière ils ont ils sont fait éliminer
dès les barrages de ligue europa dont
qui n'ont même pas joué de coupe
d'europe
dortmund me paraît quand même assez
favori sur ce groupe l'ajax est une
équipe qu'on peut plus sous-estimés
parce que chaque année ils réussissent à
sortir des joueurs et avoir une équipe
cohérente maintenant le besiktas s'est
effectivement il a largement sa chance
dans ce groupe alors on est passé pas
loin du tout en fait de la du groupe de
la mort puisque l'ac milan vient
d'attirer dans le groupe b ils avaient
le choix entre tombé dans le groupe b où
tombé dans le groupe à donc on a failli
avoir un mois le sort city paris
saint-germain life style ac milan qui
ont été le pire des groupes finalement
il tombe dans le groupe b est quand même
le groupe b ça aussi ça va être costaud
oui ça va être très très costaud là ça
va être extrêmement disputée on l'a dit
atletico liverpool porto eux ils sont là
pour jouer les huitièmes de finale pas
là pour jouer la ligue europa et pour
juste pour avoir le plaisir de jouer une
coupe d'europe derrière ce sont des
équipes qui sont maintenant habitués à
la ligue des champions les psychologies
leurs poumons a même presque deux
prétendants au titre là c'est me lancer
équipe clairement la plus forte je pense
que chapeau 4 même si le groupe dans
l'ensemble n'a pas beaucoup de vécu en
coupe d'europe c'est une équipe sur
papier que quand même impressionnante et
du coup le sait wolfsburg qui va tomber
dans le groupe g avec lille lille
sévices facebook facebook un groupe a
souffert alors ça le bouquet wolsburg
salzbourg et en autriche et en allemagne
où ils peuvent jouer l'un contre l'autre
ça ne pose pas de souci là aussi un
groupe finalement très très ouvert on a
l'impression oui assez ouvert un voile
ce box à cette partie quand même de ces
assez bonne équipe en tout cas du
chapeau 4 parce qu'ils ont fait une
assez bonne saison en bundesliga
maintenant c'est pas cadors on disait
pour lille pouvait difficilement
imaginer là je pense un tirage plus plus
abordable
je pense qu'on peut dire qu'ils ont une
chance en tout cas sur le tirage au sort
pour jouer une coupe d'europe encore en
février alors on verra comment se
dérouleront les matches mais samsung et
wolfsburg je pense pas que ce soit des
équipes totalement hors de portée pour
le losc et on nous dit le groupe b le
groupe de la mort c'est dommage on
aurait pu avoir ibra au parc des princes
pour le retour vous avez aussi parlé
tout à l'heure de la sémillante qui
aurait pu tomber avec celle ci
malheureusement il y avait 28 et du coup
un club italien ne peut pas tout mais
avec un autre club italien
alors là j'ai pas vu le club si c'était
bruges brusquer dans le groupe à il me
semble bruges donc avec la piscine par
exemple la maman de sortie comme on l'a
dit les pauvres oui voilà c'est pas de
chance pour eux c'est pas de chance pour
eux du tout parce que même la troisième
place va falloir vraiment batailler pour
pour l'arracher
j'ai envie de dire que je veux pas je
vais trop dur avec eux mais je pense
qu'ils n'ont pas pas vraiment de chance
en tout cas de jouer les huitièmes de
finale des champions et même pour une 3e
place si jamais city le psg où les psys
si l'une de ces trois équipes finit
dernière de son de son groupe c'est une
énorme désillusion pour cette équipe
parce que ce sont trois équipes qui sont
candidates aux huitièmes voire au quart
voire à la victoire finale en ligue des
champions il reste deux petites équipes
à d'attirer donc tiraspol et celles qui
étaient affichés malmö malmö qui va être
tirée à l'instant même
pourri d'auxigny que le groupe h et le
groupe de la mort chelsea juventus
zénith saint pétersbourg c'est quand
même assez tranquille et du coup a
ajouté à ça malmö malmö qui sera avec
ces trois équipes
on peut on parler un peu de paris on va
y revenir un peu plus tard à la fin de
ce tirage peut-être d'abord parler du
groupe h avec le tirage au sort de malmö
est-ce que malmö peut croire à une
troisième place dans ce groupe mais j'ai
envie de dire que ce groupe h finalement
y apprennent une mirarchi qu'est assez
logiquement établi entre chelsea la juve
le zénith malmö c'est très cohérent avec
les chapeaux
maintenant oui peut y avoir un
changement de place à chaque étage en
fait la jeune ce serait un exploit quand
même de passer devant chelsea pour les
énigmes ça serait un petit exploit aussi
de passer devant la juge comme pour
malmö ça serait quand même un petit
exploit de finir devant de zenit les
ennemis qui quand même un peu plus
habitués un peu plus expérimenté un peu
plus solide
qui a un effectif quand même un peu
supérieure je pense que pour malmö c'est
quand même un peu le plafond en tout cas
d'aller chercher une place en ligue
europa et donc le dynamo kiev qui est
tombé dans le groupe e avec le bayern
munich barcelone et benfica il reste
encore une équipe a tiré voilà c'est
dans le groupe b dans le groupe des
pardons c'est tiraspol tiraspol qu'il
fera office de motion verbard de l'an
dernier une terre de vélo en galerie
shaktar donesk et ils vont c'est bien
c'est pas pour découvrir la champion's
league voyais effectivement bas ce sont
trois équipes pour le coup habitués
surtout avec l'inter et le real et même
le shakhtar qui est très souvent présent
même si qui se retrouvent parfois pas
mal reversé en ligue europa
j'en veux dire là aussi que la
hiérarchie elle est assez assez logique
et assez instinctive en tout cas avec
l'inter le real qui sortent un type du
lot le shakhtar qui est un petit cran en
dessous même si on l'a bien vu avec la
phase de groupes de l'an dernier donc on
avait déjà l'inter le real le shakhtar
dans le même groupe on a vu que
l'intérieur et le real avait été
énormément bousculé par le shakhtar
d'ailleurs lyn thériault fini dernier
son groupe donc ça en dit long machin
gladbach aussi qui avait été quand même
très très fort sur cette phase de
groupes le real avait on avait failli
perdre le real est déterminant que deux
favoris dès la phase de groupes tout à
fait maintenant tiraspol bas c'est
clairement le petit poucet ligue des
champions
voilà je pense qu'on peut pas en
attendre grand chose c'est une équipe
sera toujours un peu cet aspect un peu
un peu piège forcément parce que c'est
une équipe que qu'on ne connaît pas
beaucoup maintenant on a quand même
clairement je pense une hiérarchie
établie en tout cas dans ce groupe d
n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos questions
à l'issue de ce 2 de ce tirage au sort
pour les pros pour les huitièmes les
premiers rencontrent les deuxièmes mais
d'accord ça toujours tip typique 83 et
capi banksy qui me dit pauvre bruges est
pauvre bruges oui effectivement voilà
vous étiez tous les deux d'accord sur ça
ikram qui me dit quelque chose à ses
dadas c'est marrant effectivement
sceller les retrouvailles
de messi avec son entraîneur son ancien
entraîneur oui effectivement avec avec
pep guardiola
on verra même si bien encore ce fantasme
aujourd'hui on l'a bien vu avec toutes
les rumeurs qui ont circulé ronaldo à
manchester city on pourrait
potentiellement avoir un duel cristiano
ronaldo lionel messi comme on l'avait
déjà eu lors d'un jubilé ce barça je me
souviens en phase de groupes
effectivement ça va être des
retrouvailles forcément forte parce que
c'est aussi la demi-finale de l'an
dernier ça va être sûrement le choc le
plus surveillé de cette phase de groupes
de ligue des champions djoko je crois
que je le dis ça pour rigoler mais être
que la troisième place pour le psg
totalement impensable ou franchement
c'est possible moi le lot de questions
que je pose c'est est-ce que s'il fait
on est d'accord quand même que si le psg
se fait sortir là c'est un cataclysme
quand même c'est clairement un
cataclysme et pour city aussi ce sont
deux prétendants au titre très très
clair
instinctivement on aurait envie de dire
que ben oui si thil psg sont utiles et 6
de leipzig est sur le papier c'est le
cas ça y'a aucun débat maintenant les
petits chats on l'a vu en phase de
groupe ils ont donné vraiment du fil à
retordre au psg l'an dernier
c'est une équipe qui est là pour jouer
les premiers rôles en ligue des
champions premier et second rôles
maximum c'est une équipe très sérieuse
maintenant oui le psg a absolument pas
le droit de se faire sortir dès la phase
de groupe ça je pense que c'est juste
impensable du côté du pg alors je
remercie tellement qu'ils nous l'ont
remercié pour cela il merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi vous êtes encore plus de
1000 à être avec nous c'est un plaisir
vous n'hésitez pas à continuer de poser
vos questions on va y répondre encore un
petit moment le tirage au sort est
terminée mais voilà on va on va parler
de tout ça on nous demande le groupe de
la mort c'est lequel moi il m'a l'air
assez alors le groupe b est pas mal
aussi quand même oui mais quand même le
groupe à mahler au su de tous clairement
dans le groupe à on a quand même trois
équipes pouvait difficilement imaginer
trois équipes aussi fortes dans le même
groupe maintenant c'est vrai que dans le
groupe b on a peut-être le groupe le
plus à la fois forte et homogène où le
sentiment que pour désigner vraiment les
deux équipes mais a toujours atletico et
liverpool qui sortent du lot c'est la
logique un peu des chapeaux quelque part
maintenant voir porto devancé la crise
qu à liverpool je pense pas que ce soit
un constable voir là c'est milan prendre
la 3e place voire même un peu taquiné
pour les huitièmes de finale c'est pas
impensable non plus effectivement le
groupe à et le groupe b c'est vraiment
les deux groupes je pense les plus les
plus forts sur le papier aujourd'hui
britney qui avait pas compris qu on
faisait de l'humour sur paris qui
pensais vraiment qu'on pensait qu'ils
allaient sortir en 3d en
ampoules non c'est quand même qu'ils
sont favoris et qui devrait normalement
sortir ce groupe b sait-on jamais nous
verrons bien on peut parler un peu ras
kamboni on ne peut pas le parler lille
dans ce tirage au sort qui s'en sort
quand même plutôt très bien bon
wolsbourg ans catherine équipe il aurait
pu trouver plus plus faible mais on peut
résumer sa part paris a eu plein des
pires tirages et lille a eu l'art des
meilleurs quand même oui tout à fait
lille pouvait difficilement imaginer un
tirage plus abordables en tout cas dans
le chapeau 2 il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'équipés qui sont moins impressionnant
sur le papier que sévit dans le chapeau
3 appareils cette bourde ça faisait
office s'il fallait désigner un petit
poucet dans le chapeau 3 c'était
probablement salzburg lille pouvait
difficilement avoir un tirage plus
abordable maintenant à voir ce qu'ils
vont en faire
j'ai envie de dire que je ne sais pas
s'il il fait partie des deux favoris de
ce groupe aujourd'hui franchement c'est
quand même très difficile à dire c'est
une équipe qui n'a tellement pas
d'expérience en coupe d'europe on le
rappelle c'est l'équipe qui a le plus
petit coefficient uefa de toutes les 32
équipes moins que le moins que chez que
le que le chef qui raffole exactement
oui lille pouvait difficilement avoir un
tirage plus abordable mais je pense
qu'il faut vraiment pas s'enflammer
là-dessus qu'il faut attendre de voir un
petit peu les matches parce que c'est
quand on sait qu'en septembre octobre on
pourra commencer à se faire une idée
lille est encore prennent très très loin
d'être sûr d'être européen en février
théophane qui lui demandait ce que si
lille est 4e c'est un cataclysme pas
vraiment quand même du coup parce que
c'était quand même des équipes qu'ils
soient là à son niveau ce serait normal
on va dire dans la de terminer troisième
mais ça certaine logique à papa réussir
à accrocher la troisième place oui et
lille ne vient pas de base avec
l'ambition de jouer les huitièmes de
file des champions je pense qu'il faut
être il faut être réaliste même s'il
avait gardé l'ossature de l'an dernier
je pense que ça aurait été difficile de
le prétendant quoique aller ce tirage la
sorte ça aurait peut-être été possible
mais le lille d'aujourd'hui de jocelyn
gourvennec a tellement changé par
rapport au livre de christophe galtier
en a tellement plus rien à voir je pense
que c'est difficile de parler de
cataclysmes s'ils font s'ils font
dernier ce serait une déception je pense
que ça sera clairement une déception
encore une fois on verra les matches on
verra les états de forme et peut-être
que wolfsburg sera une grosse surprise
en ligue des champions c'est aussi
possible
mais aujourd'hui l'huile non ça sera pas
du tout un cataclysme si jamais ils font
dernier modibo kindy le psg doit envoyer
un signal fort à toute l'europe à
travers les matches face à city et les
fiches on rappelle quand même con et que
aux premiers pas de la saison et c'est
surtout en mars qu'il faudra être
présent nous parle pas mal du groupe d
on rappelle le groupe d qui est quand
même le même groupe que l'an dernier
avec l'inter de milan real madrid et
shakhtar donetsk le sheriff tiraspol a
pris la place du borussia
mönchengladbach c'est quand même un
groupe pareil où il va ailleurs du
spectacle et on l'a vu l'an dernier qui
avait du spectacle dans ce groupe là il
va encore y en avoir oui on l'a vu l'an
dernier parce que parce que le shakhtar
a été une équipe très compliquée à jouer
pour le pour le real et pour pauline
terre on l'a vu en plus on en a parlé
tout à l'heure le réalisteur ces deux
équipes qui ont pas mal changé qui sont
un peu en crise l'inter a perdu antonio
compter sur son banc et a perdu romelu
lukaku sa star en attaque
avec une équipe comme ça qu'ils avaient
fini comme le rappelle dernier de son
groupe en ligue des champions ça avait
été un choc c'est failli coûter sa place
à antonio conte et qu'il ya derrière a
été champion d'italie donc non ils n'ont
pas regretté de le maintenir à son poste
maintenant le real est aussi en
difficulté c'est plus le real des
dernières années l'oréal triple
vainqueur de la ligue des champions mais
c'est quand même inutile il faut le
rappeler qui a fait une demi finale de
ligue des champions l'an dernier ça
reste une équipe très sérieuse mais
retrouver le shakhtar c'est pas un
cadeau pour pour l'it pour nous ni pour
le réal ni pour l'inter alors je te pose
une question de jl mais je pense que
l'on va être sur la deuxième col de la
journée c'est quand est-ce qu'on
connaîtra l'ordre des matchs alors
l'ordre des matches géant j'aurais
tendance à penser qu'il est déjà établi
normalement oui je pense qu'il est déjà
établi si alors je sais pas si tous les
sites locale ainsi de mepha déjà mis à
jour son calendrier ça c'est ses avoirs
je pense qu'il est qu'il est déjà qu'il
est déjà établi qu andry on vous laisse
on vous laisse regarder ça essayer de
trouver nous on n'a pas sous les yeux
effectivement pas encore mais il va
bientôt tomber
quelqu'un qui me dit je vois bien porto
dans le deuxième porte aux deux du
groupe b
passé liverpool atletico ils sont
clairement pas favoris quand même nom
ils sont ils sont pas favoris parce que
parce que l'atletico liverpool ça fait
partie de ces équipes un petit peu
derrière les trois cadres gros
prétendant au titre juste derrière on a
la critique au on a liverpool
porto ça reste ça reste très sérieux on
l'a vu l'année dernière sortie la
juventus n'ont pas tremblé là dessus en
quart de finale ils n'ont pas été
ridicules non plus face à chelsea qui a
ensuite gagné les champions y avait pas
de honte à sortir contre chelsea c'est
une équipe assez sérieuse assez solide
maintenant on verra aussi comment ils
vont gérer leur saison avec le
championnat portugais qui leur coûte
quand même pas mal d'énergie parce que
les courses assez effréné surtout parce
que l'année dernière porto n'a pas été
champion a été devancé par sporting
n'est pas été champions depuis des
années des années donc aujourd'hui il ya
une pression un peu plus grande
peut-être au portugal
derrière cette porte vous faut aussi
mentionner obligé de vous pensent de
mentionner de l'ac milan c'est une
équipe qui n'a pas grand chose je pense
à envier au fc porto
je pense que la lutte va être vraiment
vraiment acharnée dans ce conte plat
c'est certainement le groupe le plus
homogène et efforts à la fois alors que
la cérémonie est en train de se terminer
nous encore prendre deux trois questions
et après on va s'arrêter
on nous parle du real on nous parle de
city on a dit c'est qu'une gaffe avec la
forme actuelle du barça il va falloir du
lourd pour se défaire du r munich on l'a
dit le barça n'est clairement pas
favoris dans son nom n'est clairement
pas favoris mais plus est plus un favori
aujourd'hui à la ligue des champions là
ça fait partie peut-être ses équipes
derrière les gros favoris qu'il peut qui
peut faire quelque chose mais on l'a vu
l'année dernière lorsque lionel messi
joue encore au barça face au psg ça a
été ça a été très compliqué pour le
barça c'est une équipe aujourd'hui assez
assez limité lorsqu'on parle des plus
grosses équipes de ligue des champions
c'est un club en crise encore
aujourd'hui qui est encore très très
marqué par le départ de lionel messi
mais par toutes les crises
institutionnelles qui l'ont connu
clairement il ya le bayern au dessus
aujourd'hui par rapport au barça
maintenant le barça ça reste quand même
un favori je pense à la qualification en
8e de finale de ligue des champions par
rapport à benfica au dynamo kiev je
pense qu'il ya aucun supporters du barça
qui imagine le barça ne pas être en
ligue des champions en février rial qui
lui oppose une très bonne question c'est
qui depot 3 ou 4 des chapeaux trois ou
quatre pourraient finalement arrivé en
pourrait arriver en 8e de finale le
groupe cémoi me paraît assez ouvert ajax
ajax d'amsterdam besiktas pour prendre
la place du sporting c'est jouable
atalanta bergame ça me paraît pas mal
groupe e groupe d le chakhtior peut
tirer son épingle du jeu groupe g
salzbourg goldbrook c'est assez ouvert
groupe h peut-être au zénith oui je
pense que l'ajax a vraiment une chance
le shakhtar aussi on a vu ba l'année
dernière qu'ils étaient capables de
bousculer des équipes comme l'intérêt
l'oréal l'atalante a effectivement ça va
être très très homogène pour le coup
entre villarreal manchester united et
l'atalanta
talent au taquet largement une chance
donc parmi ces équipes au en chapeau 3
il faudra évidemment surveiller
salzbourg parce que ce groupe aussi et
pour le coup assez ouvert et le zenit
pourquoi pas je pense que ça serait
quand même un peu sur un malentendu
imaginez la juventus ne pas jouer les 8e
de finale de ligue des champions ça
serait encore une régression ils ont
déjà connu pas mal comme ça ça serait un
énorme coup dur pour la juge ça serait
un aveu d'échec pour massimiliano
allegri qui vient de revenir qui a joué
deux finales de ligue des champions avec
7 juin
je pense que le zénith est un petit peu
en dessous dans ces équipes qui peuvent
jouer la phase finale par rapport à
aller l'atalante à l'ajax et pourquoi
pas le shakhtar on avait beaucoup parlé
mais salzbourg bhl l'équipe qui est de
l'île fait quand même office de centre
de formation pour la psyché et c'est une
équipe qui avec des jeunes très
prometteurs oui effectivement c'est une
équipe qui comptera seulement certains
erding allende trop bas il y en a eu
beaucoup pour le coup c'est une équipe
qui a un qui est une structure c'est
plutôt le club disons qui a une
structure très clair qui sait où il va
c'est une équipe qui n'est pas cadeau en
coupe d'europe parce que c'est une ville
qui joue crânement sa chance
c'est une équipe jeune et j'allais dire
ambitieuse pas tant que ça justement
parce qu'il ya ce lien avec les psych
qui les limite dans leurs ambitions mais
oui c'est une équipe qui n'est pas
cadeau non plus pour lille certes
c'était peut-être une des plus faibles
du chapeau 3 mais je pense que ça va
quand même être pas un cadeau pour lille
parce que parce que c'est une équipe
sérieuse et parce que c'est une équipe
effectivement qu'il ya des joueurs qui
produit en fait des joueurs qui sont qui
vont derrière dans de très gros club on
hamad qui le dit est ce que question
pour les vu le début de saison qui est
assez poussif donc du mal à démarrer
est-ce que ça va être la même en ligue
des champions c'est pas forcément les
mêmes dynamiques qui se met en place
mais ça peut y ressembler oui c'est pas
les mêmes dynamiques et pour le coup
j'ai peur que tu as lease se retrouve un
peu avec le costume de rennes en ligue
des champions la saison dernière alors
ils ont peut-être un groupe moins relevé
de lille pour le coup ran avait
notamment dû jouer jouer chelsea qui
n'était pas un cadeau même même si ce
n'était pas encore un chelsea au top de
sa forme
meyer peut-être plus gros banc une
équipe plus complète que leur haine de
l'an dernier oui effectivement être que
rennes avait un peu plus de deux vécu
d'expérience en tout cas dans son groupe
dans sa dynamique avec art et julien
stéphant la jocelyn gourvennec vient
d'arriver pour l'instant il a un peu du
mal à trouver la formule je pense qu'à
des exemples assez frappant çà et et
youssouf yazici qui a été un petit peu
un petit peu barque balai sur sur le
terrain on cherche un petit peu sa place
on sent que jocelyn gourvennec qui
tâtonne encore la ligue des champions ce
pas vraiment un cadeau pour se mettre en
route et pour vraiment construire son
équipe effectivement eh bien écoutez
merci beaucoup ou d'avoir été avec nous
on va terminer cela il n'y a plus
d'autres questions si vous voulez revoir
il sera disponible sur youtube sur le
site du figaro et moi je vous donne
rendez vous mardi prochain mardi
prochain on sera encore avec sébastien
pour faire un nouveau live un point
mercato puisque c'est la fin du mercato
vous pourrez venir mardi prochain nous
poser toutes vos questions merci d'avoir
été avec nous pendant très longtemps
pendant une heure et demie on se lève a
duré une heure et demie avec ce tirage
au sort d'avoir été nombreux à poser des
questions d'avoir apporté de
l'interactivité merci à vous juste une
lettre très rapidement une question
paris favoris cette année bastien comme
on l'a dit city chelsea le bayern le psg
sont les équipes qui sortent du lot
aujourd'hui n'est pas un gros favoris
non un gros favoris c'est très difficile
en tout cas en août c'est impossible
d'en nommer un je pense parfois salée
mais là aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué
même si le pg est très sexy sur le
papier encore une fois on l'a dit messi
neymar bout même pas encore joué cette
saison on va attendre de voir mais oui
le pg fait clairement partie des 3,4
gros favoris très bien et bien écoutez
merci beaucoup merci à vous une fois de
plus d'avoir été avec nous pendant la
durée de ce live et nous on vous dit à
mardi 17h pour le dernier point mercato
avant la grande clôture des transferts